Õpetaja: Nii nüüd siis on rekordimas.
Õpetaja: Ee, ahah, ee. Nüüd, kus ta rekordimas ma saan selle lingi juba ära võtta? Mis Hõlmab kahte.
Õpetaja: Ee, kahtes Kahtle. Kus sa Zo Zoomi logo. Ma ei näe või
Õpetaja: aega. Ei, no mis? Toimus ruum lahti, kui kadus,
Õpetaja: ee, Et ma panen ära selle lingi, et mul ei ole.
Õpetaja: Panen selle praeguse lingi. Mis seal hetkel siin stal? Ib
Õpetaja: vaid process. I selle võib panna siia.
Õpetaja: Vaatan korra video üks, ja kaks. Nüüd mänginasti siia ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on siis siin igaüks ja kaks. Video, Üks ja Kaks nii Vaškoka.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi on teist nõus ee võtma ka jälle?
Õpetaja: Niiöelda videosid enda peale.
Õpetaja: Nädalavahetusel slash mingi õhtu ära teha.
Õpetaja: Catameri.
Õpetaja: Jah, abi proovida.
Õpetaja: Em.
Õpetaja: No ma võtan. Siis panen Jaanuse. See on nagu
Õpetaja: Ee Jaanus. Jaanus. Jaanus. Jaanus. Aga selles mõttes, et saan, on ju kaks videot. Vaata, et saaks, teha
Õpetaja: et Jaanus. Kõik ei saa ka teha. Kas keegi. On veel nõus, Cloudford I,
Õpetaja: kui kõige Rohkem ei ole siis Andrus. Vaata, sa üritad igale poole vaadata nagu. Aga.
Õpetaja: No sa teeksid selle ära. See vabatahtlikult Ee, sunniviisiliselt on alati Kõige parem, et ei trügiks.
Õpetaja: Ei, ee, jah oled. Olge ole vaad. Olge tänatud, Ee, Täname ette ja järgi Ee, loomulikult on hea ikkagi saada. Põhimõtteliselt need videod nagu ilusti. Kenasti
Õpetaja: kätte siis oleks hea.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Ei, te võite tegelikult need Md failid ka panna. Sinna samma kausta Andrus näiteks pani. Ma nägin Nii on kõige lihtsam. Siis siis ma saan.
Õpetaja: Ja et, ee, siis on. Saate mulle isegi kõige lihtsam, see on Copy Based on need desktop Il. Ja siis tõsta kõik ühe korra ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelt Pulli pärast. Võiks üldse vaadata, kas nad siin ka kuidagi üldse avaneksid. Ma võin korra proovida. Ee, näiteks. Ee. Andrus
Õpetaja: Ei, seda ei pidanudki linkima. Aga ma just praegu tahtsin korra proovida, Et kuidas ta nagu seda ava avaks? Sest et see Md formaat on Niuke täiesti teistsugune formaat. Browser peaks oskama seda tegelikult ka
Õpetaja: ee Remberdada, et selles mõttes ma korra pulli pärast proovin. Võtan võibolla video kaks. Kus see video üks on? Eks proovime, Sellega
Õpetaja: eks? See on Siis seitsmenda video. Ma lihtsalt täitsa flirdin selle mõttega. Võibolla Olekski hea nüüd üldse siin hoida Ee. Siis oleks kõik nagu käinud täitsa ühes kohas.
Õpetaja: Aga seal on ainult jumet. Kui ta kuidagi kuvab seda inimväärselt
Õpetaja: nii seitsmes esimene video Md fail. Ma panen korra selle lihtsalt siia Ja vaatan, mis juhtub, kui selle peale vajutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, jah, mingeid asju. Isegi koodiploki Päris koodiplokina ei näita. Noh, loetav ta on tegelikult
Õpetaja: kõige Elusam ei ole, et see on ikkagi. Ta näitab Native tekstina. On ju huvitav. Nagu Mingid noolekesed asjad on
Õpetaja: Mm, Huvitav, Kas sa müüd Pluginati ära,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, Jah, seda võiks ka vaadata. Kas äkki lihtsalt mingi proginaga oleks seda?
Õpetaja: Mis? Ma teen? Teen korra ühe lahti. No Vaatame korra, et kuidas.
Õpetaja: Ahah Google Dox Connect More apps.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra, Mis siin oleks, ma otsin, panen või Mark Down Tox Tomato,
Õpetaja: aga Kas need on nüüd kuidagi siin? Samas? See nagu toimib või see on mingi. Aga See ei ole see. Vaata, see on see, et Tee mingi asi Md failiks. Vaata, onju? Mul oleks nagu Mark.
Õpetaja: Ee, oleks põhimõtteliselt nüüd mis huvitaks Google Drive. Oh, oh, see juba
Õpetaja: Kuidas See töötab. Open on Google Drive. No extra software. Kui ma ütlen Instyle, mida see tähendab, siis
Õpetaja: on üks vä. No kuustuhat inimest ikka Nagu jätkuvalt. Nagu proovime ära, nagu see ei tööta. Aga äkki mul töötab.
Õpetaja: Ma Vaatan parem Extension it otseseks pärast.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et Chrome Extensions oleks tegelikult niuke asi, mis võiks olla, et universaalselt. Aga samas, kuidas ta seal Google Drive selle lahti teeb, Onju Vaatame, ka ära.
Õpetaja: No sellel on vähemalt parem skoor, eks? Ole
Õpetaja: üle viiesaja tuhande. Ma võtan korra lihtsalt. Kuidas see käiks?
Õpetaja: Kaheksa minutit, eks?
Õpetaja: Ilus,
Õpetaja: ma proovin korra ära. Kas see on nagu mingisugune asi, mis ee üldse töötab? Sest et. Okei, ta on Martin Viewer, Aga vaata, see fail siin Otseselt ei olnud nagu ju
Õpetaja: Kus see õli kadus? Ära mul siin otsida. Uuesti
Õpetaja: kuskil siin. Ma toimetasin korraks onju,
Õpetaja: ei põhimõtteliselt siin liiga palju asju lahti teeb, kui ma teen selle lahti.
Õpetaja: Noh, Nd siin on, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kas see Extension üldse tuli Tensions Mõned Substantions, Kuidas See töötab.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt arvan, et see. Vaata, see on nagu oli tundus olevat
Õpetaja: Noh, see on nagu mingi asja sees. Vaata, et siin ei ole punkt Md, onju?
Õpetaja: Hea küll, ei vääri hetkel küünlaid.
Õpetaja: Jumal, temaga mõtleb seda asja veel Natukene leiab mingi aeg, chat. Iga saab ka võibolla konsultida.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähme meie oma arenduse juurde ja
Õpetaja: teeme siia. No võiks teha korra, et panna üldse backend tööle,
Õpetaja: võiks teha ka selle pulli, et panna frontend i tööle. Aga enne kui frontend tööle panna.
Õpetaja: Aga ma vaataks üle. Nüüd. Aa, te saate ka kaasa teha. See pole otseselt nagu.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla testimise mõttes oleks hea teha see frontend kaust lahti
Õpetaja: ja otsida siit see konflikt fail üles
Õpetaja: teha, Siin see trikk ära, et Control Shift seitse. Control shift. Seitse. Et ee. Sisse niiöelda kommenteerida, et ee, sõnumid läheksid Ee, kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend kohaliku serveri vastu. Võibolla front käima panna. Minu meelest see võib olla hotelli. Lood ei toeta ka. Ma ei ole kindel, kas see töötab. On The Fly või mitte.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, siin on ka selline. Siin on, Mäletate? Ma rääkisin, et kõik need rajad. Vaata, saab
Õpetaja: ee alustada Source kataloogist ätt I märgiga.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, kui kuskil Vaata, pidime Frontis nii öelda. Defineerima mingi failirada
Õpetaja: eraldi. Vaata, et, ee, ma ei tea mingi pildi sisu Või Mis iganes seal on, et ätt. Niiöelda siin on kuidagi defineeritud, et ättiga
Õpetaja: alustatakse Source kaustas.
Õpetaja: Mul on plaanis seda asja kasutada, ja Ee, sisselogimine on meil näiteks tehtud vastatajale pakendis ja linnade rippeni.
Õpetaja: Aga et seda demoda, siis ma mõtlen, et on üks probleem. Ee, see Leht, kus me peame pangaautomaatide lehele maanduma peale logimist. Ee, kutsub välja Gat Cities, Aga ta küsib ka, kohe, Aga see annab meil siis ju error I,
Õpetaja: et ee. Backend ju ei vasta. Ja siis on rakendatud kohe see, et navigate.
Õpetaja: Ma olen siin ee et probleem on selles, et lihtsalt demoda. No nii palju saab demoda, et ta läheb kuhugi lehele
Õpetaja: ee taustal. Saan teha inspekti lahti. Saame vaadata, et backhand vastab.
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan siia. Admin,
Õpetaja: üks, kaks, kolm, aa. Mul on midagi jama ka proovida, Sest et nüüd peaks olema ju vale kasutaja nimi parool.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma panen mingi päris asja? Üks, kaks, kolm, ee. Läksime siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Ahah, meil ei olegi siin kuskil seda ära markeerita, et tulevad kõik linnad,
Õpetaja: et läks loogiline. Niiöelda sõnum Back end vastas
Õpetaja: ja läks Get Cities sõnum ja keegi vastas.
Õpetaja: Aga et, ee, see City Id. See hetkel ei vasta keegi. Not sound.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis tema saatis sõnumi. Back end ile ja Back end viitesadat ei vastanud, vaid ütles, et. Kuule, ma ei leia
Õpetaja: nihukest Urli Põhimõtteliselt ka enda. Võib, öelda, et dispetšer vastas, et. Thanks for Calling, aga
Õpetaja: mul ei ole kellelegi seda kõne suunata.
Õpetaja: Midagi juba näeme, et töötab.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, siis. See Get Cities. Me suures pildis saime tehtud. Ma mõtlesin, see väike Muudatus nüüd siin Ka
Õpetaja: Võtin selle ka. Ära siis uuesti Viis komplit. Oi, Peep. Kuus. Kompliit oli. See juba läks. Näeb igastahe,
Õpetaja: et ee. Nüüd võiks siis. Ee.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võiks siis ee, teha selle liigutuse, et ee, mörsida see ära.
Õpetaja: Õpetaja Brunch Il peab minema sellele branšile, kuhu tõmbab Merchile tehtud töö.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siin nii palju aru saanud Onju keerulisem siin toimetada.
Õpetaja: Merch B. Pintu. Õpetaja
Õpetaja: nörtsimine toimus küsib, kas vana Haru ära kustutada, võib ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Ja siis võib.
Õpetaja: Push Id on. Mis on siin?
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd selles? Ee, uues harus ka ära
Õpetaja: ja Kui ma selle taaski kuidagi siit kuskilt ülesse leian,
Õpetaja: siis Ee, võiks selle ka liigutada, et see on Done
Õpetaja: nii tervisel on siis pangaautomaatide Asukoha info
Õpetaja: kaheksaga, et kõigepealt on pangaautomaatide asukoha info ja pärast on pangaautomaatide asukohainfo koos teenustega.
Õpetaja: Ee, meelega on niimoodi kaheksa tehtud et natukene Step by Step minna.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, mis Peep seitse räägib,
Õpetaja: eks? Selle suureks beeeb. Seitse, Bep. Seitse, Ee, Räägitakse tabelites. Ee, si siin taaskis, mängivad rolli Tabelit. City Allocation.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et loo teenus, et siis see võtab. Ee Request. Parameetri Query Parameetri mõlemat. Kasutatakse miks. Ta on match rohkem. Ma olen vist query Parameetrit näinud ja. Springi Pool oleme. Request Parameetrit näinud aga, Heal lapsel mitu. Nime
Õpetaja: et, ta võtab siis nimelise Parameetri City Id võrdub on ju. Teenus Peab tagastama pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot. Kui City Id on null, siis tagastatakse kõik asukohad.
Õpetaja: Siin ma olen välja mõelnud ülikavala lahenduse sellisel repositoris Ee millega, saab seda teha, et kui null on, siis võta kõik
Õpetaja: City idea mingi muu väärtusega, siis Tagastatakse vastava linna alla kuuluvad pangaautomaadid.
Õpetaja: Andmete pärimusel saadetakse Back and serverile kett sõnum
Õpetaja: koos Request parameetriga. City Id Mis on. Siis number näide saadetavast sõnumist.
Õpetaja: Teenus peab tagastama listi massiivi objektidest, milles on alljärgnevad väljad
Õpetaja: objektidest. Meil peaks olema Aa, meil on vaja mingit objekti meil on vaja mingit klassi,
Õpetaja: kus on alljärgnevad väljad. Location Id Cityname Location Name.
Õpetaja: Kui ühtegi asukohta ei leidu, siis peab tagastama vea teataväljadega
Õpetaja: Ee, kasutada ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. Rr kod on No Location Found näidis. Kui on kõik linnad
Õpetaja: Cation Id Cityname Location name Location Id Cityname Location Name Kui City Id on kaks,
Õpetaja: tagastatakse ainult vastava linna alla. Kuus on asukohtade list siin nagu näide ka Prisma Pandi Selver ja, tead, Ja kui on mingi niukene asi, mille kohta midagi ei leitud, siis visatakse. Error ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati
Õpetaja: api dokumentatsiooni jaoks ka kirjas, mida võiks siis kirjutada. No suures pildis on mõtteselge.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ei ole, võin teha kõrvale ka
Õpetaja: Space S.
Õpetaja: Võin teha kõrvale ka Frontend Taski Et, ee, tuletada. Meelde.
Õpetaja: Üldse tegeletakse balsamikuga. Ära vahepeal lahti ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, tahaks ju natukene. Nüüd, kus te olete lähemal. Oi, aga mina ei mäleta enam siin Balsamic Cloud is. Seda
Õpetaja: Jah, Ahaa. Võibolla oleks aeg teile näidata ka tegelikult balsamikuga. Kas teate niukest kohta? Nagu temp Mail
Õpetaja: Ongi ei kasuta midagi. Niukest varem.
Õpetaja: Temporary email adress.
Õpetaja: Forget about spam advertising mailings hacking and taking robots. Keep your real mailbox clean and Secure
Õpetaja: Tempmail Provide Temperary Secure Awams Free Disposable. Email adress. Näete seda minu emaili aadressi?
Õpetaja: Palun Saatke mulle kirja.
Õpetaja: Tulevad siia paksem.
Õpetaja: Noh, soovin ka proovida asja. Ma ei julge sinna vaataja jaoks. Äkki keegi saab teada. Kuskilt hakkab mingit. Ee,
Õpetaja: ma võin ruttu saata. Bye, proovime.
Õpetaja: Põmm.
Õpetaja: Hei, hei, see on
Õpetaja: Katsun ikka.
Õpetaja: Pakun, et asi on pigem selline Google, kui ehei tuli.
Õpetaja: Aga point on see, et see on kandida Senikaua, kuni ma ei tea, ee, lahti või ta mingi aeg kaob ära,
Õpetaja: et sa nendel on. Muidugi see. Vaata, kui sa oled mingis kohas kuskil reganud või kasutanud. Ja siis on see Forget Password. Siis on nagu. Kust sa seda saad? Enam
Õpetaja: Ee Ja siis nad ütlevad. Aga Money Money või Open?
Õpetaja: Ee, mingi Niukene Staff on Ee, Paljud kohad juba tajuvad selle või tunnevad ära mingi tehisintellekti. Mis iganes, et Paljud kohad ütlevad, Kui sa üritad sellega kuskil regada, ennast
Õpetaja: siis ei ei saa. Näiteks Chat.
Õpetaja: Aga muidu oleks nagu see, et Ee Hei Soovin Creator Account
Õpetaja: Email. Palun. Väga nimeks. Loomulikult. John Smith ei ärata mingisugust tähelepanu.
Õpetaja: Ma hakkasin mõtlema, aga lõpuks seal ikka väga palju nipidirisid. Vaata, Sest nad hakkavad mõtlema. Aga John Smith? Nagu
Õpetaja: suspassword.
Õpetaja: Ju te
Õpetaja: kolm.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, enter confirm your email.
Õpetaja: No problem, my fan, No problem, balsamik.
Õpetaja: Ma võibolla siit saan selle kätte. Tegelikult noki. Ma saan lihtsalt copida paremini,
Õpetaja: et see on minu uus kood.
Õpetaja: Ma ausalt öeldes nutan. Kui nad ee, üks päev selle kinni panevad,
Õpetaja: siis ma lihtsalt klõpsin neid, et kes ma olen ja ja Founder olen, miks Mitte
Õpetaja: See on siis see koht, kus saab ee joonistada. Ee, neil on ka selline asi. Nagu. Ai,
Õpetaja: ee, Mulle üks ee Madal vaade siin. Ee, konkreetsel Board Il
Õpetaja: t mull Euks Login ma. Oi,
Õpetaja: jah, kas see nüüd läks Või läinud?
Õpetaja: Generating screen punkt.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, Eesti Helen sõber Pinking.
Õpetaja: Aga See mingi. Kreditid liiguvad. Vaata, noh, jah, noh, teeme lahti. Uus konto.
Õpetaja: John Smith.
Õpetaja: Ainuke asi on Editiga. Vaadake, mis ta teeb on põrsas. On ju, et ta nagu ei saa väga hästi aru, et, ee, olevaid Ta oskab uuesti teha ja siin tegelikult on. No ma näit. Ma teen eraldi seda ka, et siin on tegelikult ee boardid,
Õpetaja: et ee, ports, et selles mõttes, et see võiks üks vaade olla. See on järgmine vaade. Lihtsalt paneb nime. Vaata, ma ei, tea, Login
Õpetaja: siis need uuevad. Ma ei tea, no goud saate vist mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Noh, suht vähese vaevaga tegelikult saab. Aga mis on siis nagu parim asi on see, et nende freemium trial perioodi sees on sellised asjad nagu projekti, import ja eksport.
Õpetaja: Import. Mingi nende enda faili laiend Balsamic Bankrest.
Õpetaja: Taraa.
Õpetaja: Noh, see värk. Mäletate,
Õpetaja: mis ma tahan, et Te hakkaksite ka mõtlema, on see, et. Ee. Ja seda ma Seda ma aitan Selles osas ka. Et. Ee, korra. Ma lähen sellesse Mode
Õpetaja: Ee, Kus saab niimoodi vaadata, et minu jaoks on nagu tähtis see, et te hakkate tegema asju nagu
Õpetaja: sellisel viisil et tal on Kindlad Post It üks on, mis on niiöelda? Vaata enda kohta roll. Faili nimi, Frontend Rada.
Õpetaja: Vaatega seotud lisainfo, kõik mida tegelikult ise, võiksite omavahel teada selle vaate kohta väga stiilselt. Vajutad seda nuppu ja siis liigud sinna Ja mingi niuke info vaatamata siit ära
Õpetaja: kogu Niukene vajalik Asi, mis te mõtlete
Õpetaja: Ja siis sõnumid, mis kõik lähevad
Õpetaja: ja et nad oleks nagu kindla struktuuriga, mida oleks lihtne mõista
Õpetaja: nagu need need Võtmesõnad. Ee, ma arvan, et selle jaoks me teeme mingisuguse Skill I,
Õpetaja: mis aitab ee konkreetseid. Ee, niiöelda postiteid luua küsib sulle, et, noh, Mis sa tegema pead?
Õpetaja: Mis see Jason on? Mis see rada? Ta küsib mulle küsimuse, aga ta igal juhul teeb selle täpselt sellises stiilis, Sellepärast, et mõte on see, et seda sama informatsiooni te hakkate pärast engineerides kasutama.
Õpetaja: Taaskegenereerida Jah, et ee selle kavandamine alles siis, kui
Õpetaja: ei Vastupidi, seda hakkad kohe kavandama.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga mõtle nagu nende sõnumite mõttes. Ee, see on natukene. Nüüd on niimoodi. Vaata, et Ee, Vaadake need Sõnumid, mis on Vaata mingi. Username ja võtame natukene midagi paremat, et läheme Grammi võrra edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, läheme näiteks siia. Kus on juba see Asi onju, et
Õpetaja: natukene saab. Aga Ta vist ta teeb ainult kõiki neid muid asju suuremaks.
Õpetaja: Aga ütleme niimoodi, et see praegult ei olegi Nagu nii tähtis. Lihtsalt see mõte, et loomulikult. Vaadake, siin on igasugused nimed. Location Id Location Name. Noh, see ju viitab tegelikult andmebaasi veergutele ka onju? Tabelitele veergudele,
Õpetaja: et kui te hakkate oma projekte tegema, siis ee, te. Ma arvan et teil on mõistlik teha natukene mõlemat korraga
Õpetaja: Teil on oma mingi. Idee Vaata, mida te tahate teha. Loomulikult, võtke ai appi igatepidi, et nagu neid asju arutada ja niiöelda teha, onju Ee, et ee, ai abil võiks kindlasti. Ta võiks teha mingisuguse põhja.
Õpetaja: Ee, mudelist andmebaasi mudelist.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, nagu paralleelselt natukene hakata toimetama ühe ja teisega. Ja ma näitan seda keskkonda, kus edaspidi siis nagu võiks toimetada ka niiöelda siis selle andmebaasi mudeliga, seal on samamoodi tasuta konto Ja. Ja kõik nii kõik see muu muusika.
Õpetaja: Ee, sest et natuke on keeruline. Noh, vanasti, ma ütlesin, et tehke täiesti front valmis on ju aga natukene keeruline. On mõelda nimedele ja seostele. Vaata, kui sul ei ole ju andmebaasi. Ka, Vaata et siis
Õpetaja: Kaina natukene mõlemad korraga. No kui sul on mingi vaade, siis sa peaksid mõtlema, et mul peaks olema mingi tabel. Vaata
Õpetaja: teda, saab täiesti. Ise teha ka, ma Mõtlen nagu, et ei pea kasutama, Aga ma arvan, et see on üks Niukene hea koht, kus aeg kasutada
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et selle jaoks Mingisuguse dokum Dokumendi Teeme valmis ja paneme teie projekti juurde. Ka. Mingisugused teatud nõuded.
Õpetaja: Noh, tabeli nimed ainsuses. Ee, Tabeli nime Veergu veergudes ei korda Pole vaja. Teeme ainult oma koodi pikemaks. Lihtsalt mida? Lühemad Nimed,
Õpetaja: Need samad kõik asjad on peegeldatud. Koodis kaovad, et üritaks nagu vältida. Vaata, et no siin on näiteks sama. Vaata, kui sul on rol tabel, vaata siis sinna. Ei ole mõtet teha näiteks mingi role name Või panna role.
Õpetaja: Vaata, on ju nagu siin on Nagu vaja mõelda, et kui sul on role tabel ja sa paned sinna, siis see User Role Name on, Sest Id ka, on ju Vaata, kõik kõik tabelid, onju? Role, Id, user, Id ja nii edasi, onju, et kuskil Nagu Ei ole mõtet korrata. Ee, nagu seda
Õpetaja: Niiöelda Ehk tabeli nimel.
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on nagu. See, et umbes selliselt tahaks toimetada
Õpetaja: ja tuleme selle juurde tagasi ka veel.
Õpetaja: Miks ma seda üldse näitasin? Aga ma tahtsin tegelikult lihtsalt konkreetset vaadet vaadata. Ee, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ja sama sama Asi on nüüd. Ee. Me tahame saada ka suuremaks. Ta on nii tobe, tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga ma niimoodi selles vaates saab.
Õpetaja: Siin saab natukene suuremaks välja, siis ma ei saa neid nuppe niimoodi vajutada. Lükk käib sellest tabelist, on ju
Õpetaja: Aga esialgu ainult niimoodi, et need kaks
Õpetaja: sellepärast, Et, ee, tege. Noh, päeva lõpuks me peame need asjad ka juurde tegema. Aga siin on selline olukord, kus me ei saa esimese korraga kõiki andmeid kätte
Õpetaja: meil ei ole. Me peame kahest tabelist nii öelda. Küsima.
Õpetaja: Ee City. Tabel on siin kenasti ja teada see töötas, on Ju Ee, taask. Siis rääkis meil põhimõtteliselt, et
Õpetaja: esimese kahe veeru saaks ära täita.
Õpetaja: Täpselt nagu siin sellel pildil oli esimesed kaks linn asukoht Ja tegelikult Id, mis on taustal.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida, ee, ka anname, niiöelda front endile, aga seda ei kuvata, lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: Aga see on kui klikid peale ja avaneb modal ja teada. Ja siis see kõik põhimõtteliselt nagu toimib tänu sellele Id, Le et Niukestes tabelites ja või siis kaartides Vahet pole, kuidas see on konstrueeritud.
Õpetaja: Tähtis on, ee aru saada seda, et kui sa lähed kuskile uuele vaatele või mis on seotud, sellega Siis sul ongi seda Id vaja,
Õpetaja: et siis päritakse seal uuel vaatel. Kõik need andmed, mis kuuluvad selle asja juurde, kui neid on vaja,
Õpetaja: Et, ee, see on siis kuidas
Õpetaja: need asjad tavaliselt on? Omavahel ühendatud tiib.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme siiski juurde. Et, ee, kuskilt peab alustama.
Õpetaja: No kust võiks alustada.
Õpetaja: No võibolla alustame sellest, et teeme taski. Ee, haru.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et ee, New branch.
Õpetaja: Ee, palju seitse ajab.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Saate. Te saate kasutada neid samu profile. Te saate isegi teha projekti siia. Samma Spacey. Kus Me kaime toimetame,
Õpetaja: Kui te tahate
Õpetaja: ee võite ka teha personaalse konto ja üksteist invite ida ja teha. Vaata, onju? Aga noh, põhimõtteliselt ta ligipääs
Õpetaja: seal on varasemaid projekte olnud. Ma mingi hetk olen neid ära kustutanud, et kui tulla siia alla.
Õpetaja: Ma olen nüüd ära kustutanud, aga siin on olnud tegelikult veel
Õpetaja: Õpilased on teinud mingeid projekte vaata siis kasutanud Chira ei ole nagu kohustuslik. Ee, kuidagi. Aga selles mõttes sellegipoolest võib kasutada. Kui tahate, võite kas ka pealkirja panna,
Õpetaja: Ma teine Ma pigem nagu soovitan teil kasutada seda. Vaata, et hakke tegema dokumentatsiooni ja taaske asju hoopis sinna. Otse
Õpetaja: ee, otse sinna Projekti
Õpetaja: titabile Endal on tegelikult ka taasklid. Ja. Ja neid saab ära Connect Ida sees. Sõna otseses mõttes saab taaski teha. Aga ma lausa mõtlesin nagu Md faile,
Õpetaja: Sest et, ee, see niikuinii see mõte on
Õpetaja: see, et. Ee, teil teil on vaja nagu teha seda niimoodi, või et kui te, Noh, selles mõttes mina õpetan, kuidas teha projekti niimoodi, et ta on jätkusuutlik. Ja niiöelda tehtav. Teil on vaja põhimõtteliselt päeva lõpuks ee saada Siis, ee, piltide kujul või Pdf. Mis iganes see
Õpetaja: kogu see teie planeeritud niiöelda. Ee, vaade
Õpetaja: Ee koos infoga, mis sõnumid käivad ja nii Edasi, Saada see Mitte back end Il, vaid Vabandust,
Õpetaja: Sealt te saate juba Cloud Code iga toimetada ja öelda, et Okei Ee, see vaade, Mina hakkan ee tegema, onju? Siin on üks konkreetne teenus. Palun Teeme selle kohta taaskeid.
Õpetaja: Taaski tegemisel. Loomulikult seda tasub, siis selle jaoks tasub Skill teha nagu et Skilliga seda siis kogu aeg käivitada. Ja see on, nagu, et igas taaskis peab olema siis nagu ee kirjeldus mingi Kriteeria. Mingisugused Ee, nõuded. Ee, ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui ta teeb selle taaski välja, siis see kind on lihtsalt plaan. Vaata, mis süsteemis Peab nagu toimuma muudatused. Siis on natukene vaja sellele ee plaanile otsa. Vaadata, et, ee, missuguse info? Niiöelda siis? Ee, niiöelda. Ai kokku pani Vaata, Kuidas tema mõistab. Mis see taskus on.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleks seda natukene. Nagu selles mõttes, et nagu. Et kas siin on nagu igas nurgad Nagu, ee, olemas
Õpetaja: saab kasutada niukest asja nagu grill. Me. Muidugi Ma ei tea, kas seda iga tasku puhul jaksaks teha ja siis ka Nagu ta nagu leiab igasuguseid häguseid kohti. Vaata, mis? Muidugi siis ongi. Küsimused. Vaata küsimused arendajale, et, noh, taskis tegelikult on mingi asi, mis Ei ole kahtepidi nagu üheselt mõistetav
Õpetaja: või ei ole defineeritud on, ju ja? Siis ta tegelikult aitaks seda taaski niiöelda timmida Nagu paremaks ja, Siis kui sa mingi hetk ütled, et teie implementatsioon nüüd on teie valik. Vaata, on ju? Te saate kasutada niukest head Skill I, Nagu Kavatseme nimetada.
Õpetaja: Mis siis Näiteks selle task i pealt. Põhimõtteliselt, ee,
Õpetaja: teeb ühe uue dokumendi valmis, kus ta kirjeldab. Vaata, et,
Õpetaja: ee, põhimõtteliselt mida Te mis muudatused te nagu peaksite süsteemis tegema. Aga mitte niimoodi, et ta koodi ette kirjutab.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on teil võimalik niiöelda proovida, et Kas Te oskate nagu päris oma käpakestega selle asja valmis? Progeda niimoodi, et teil on kirjeldus ees. Vaata nagu vihjed, Vaata, et mida te Nagu Ukraine, Nagu peaksite tegema. Aga koodi ennast ei ole.
Õpetaja: No siis te loomulikult saate neid asju lahendada. Ja kui kuskil jäte hätta, siis Te saate veel aega suhelda. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: pean niukest asja tegema. Ma nagu päris täpselt ei mõista või mida iganes. Anna mulle mingi veevihjeid, Või mis iganes, onju. Ja siis ta saab nagu neid aidata. Aga noh, loomulikult siis saab ka proovida, et kuidas oleks siis nagu Vibe Coodida on see, et, ee. Ütled, et. Okei, tee mulle palun sellest taskist lahendus, aga nüüd tuleb lahendus üle vaadata.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: ee, üksainukene Nõue on teile Teie Vastutate oma koodi eest ise ja teie, ee ühtegi rida koodi te ennem edasi ei liigu. Kui te mõistate seda, et Kui kasutasid Ai, D, Mis selle koodi tegi, siis sina pead mõistma täpselt kuidas, see töötab mis. Moodi. See käib
Õpetaja: mis? Midagi toimetab Ja teeb, on ju? Ja siis, kui näiteks mina tulen, istun kõrvale ja näiteks vaatan ja leian mingisuguse koha, mis mind huvitab, Ma saan Kohe vaadata, keda süüdistada. On ju, et vaadata, et kes need koodiread siia lisas ja siis on nagu küsimus, Nagu, et palun
Õpetaja: räägi, mulle Kuidas see toimib, onju? Ja mida, nagu keerulisemat lahendust teete? Erinevates süsteemides võib ka olla keerulisemad taskid ja kohad on ju Kui on nagu niuksed keerulisemad asjad siis tegelikult on kohustus. Ma arvan ka teil tutvustada seda oma tiimiliikmetele.
Õpetaja: Kuidas te tutvustate midagi, nagu et kas te tutvustate Niimoodi, et. Noh, et ahi tegi. Vaata või nagu et näete,
Õpetaja: siin on nüüd selline värk. Vaata, et see töötab nüüd niimoodi ja see Kogu selle asja saime kokku niimoodi, et. Ee, Ai on täiesti lubatud. Ee, ma ütlen. Ma jätan täiesti vabad käed on välja arvatud see, Mis on keelatud One shot imine.
Õpetaja: See ei ole nagu see point. Ei, asi isegi ei tule koledale. Võib tulla isegi. Okei, aga vaata Te tulite õppima. Ee, Tuletan veelkord Meelde Ei tulnud projekti tegema. Mul üksuspuha. Ee, Kui valmis projekt jõuab või või mitte, onju see aeg. On niikuinii nii piiratud.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis siin on? Ee, tähtis on pigem ikkagi see, et ma näen, kuidas te tiimidena töötate, kuidas te arutate asju, kuidas te ise pusite. Kuidas te proovite ikkagi ai abiga õppida
Õpetaja: ja teha samaaegselt, onju? Ja loomulikult lõpu poole võib juba veits panna, Nagu kui tahate ikkagi midagi, nagu rohkem valmis saada, võite Ai le ka usaldada. Ka siis selle klausliga, et alati peate nagu mõistma nagu, Mis kood teeb, Sest kui Ai hakkab panema? Sind võib hakata pakkuma teile hoopis teistsugust lähenemist, kui meie oleme teinud ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: see on see koht. Vaata kus siis, ma ütlen. Siis tulebki väga lihtsalt sisse. Et Ma tunnen kohe ära. Te tunnete ise ka ära Vaata, ei saa mitte midagi aru. Vaata, sa ei ka mitte midagi aru, et ee, peale vaadates, et siis lihtsalt kohustus ongi see, et kui ta koodi, teeb Siis see vastutus. Jääb teile. See ei ole muutunud tänase seisuga.
Õpetaja: Aa arendaja vastutab selle koodi. Eest. Te ei saa minna kuhugi tulevikus kohta. Ja
Õpetaja: keegi teeb päris Code Review D ja vaatab ilusti üle. Vaata ja ütleb, et kuule, mis toimib siin nagu. Tule, Tule, räägi mulle Ai tegi
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta saatis selle nii kaugele. Kui. Kui kaugele, et Nagu seda poleks teha Nagu reeglite järgi, Aga No see enam läks sinna, kuhu ta läks. No okei, kütt, nagu. Väga koolis
Õpetaja: jah. Et, ee et, selles mõttes noh. Mõte, ongi see et one shot iga. Vaata, ta tulekski siis. Tegelikult. Ee, võibolla täiesti eri nagu niiöelda sellise mustriga, mida te üldse ei tunne ja see pole point niikuinii. Ma ütlen, et
Õpetaja: et, ee, ma. Ma nagu päriselt ise nagu pooldan Ja usun ka seda, et kui sa tahad midagi teha. Vaata, on ju siis, kui sa tahad midagi suurt teha ja jätkusuutlikult. Noh, nüüd endal tekkis üks Brex siin naabriga,
Õpetaja: Ee, et proovida mingisugust põnevat asja korra, et see on kohe ette teada, et. Ee, see. Kui sa lähed seda one shot ima, siis gonna work,
Õpetaja: aga Siis see ei ole jätkusuutlik, kui sa ise niimoodi jupi kaupa ehitad mingit asja üle süsteemselt
Õpetaja: süsteemselt. Vaata, ja iga asja kohta on ka dokumentatsioon. Iga nagu asja koht on seal samas projektis ka olemas. Taas
Õpetaja: siis tulevikus on väga lihtne ja hea tegelikult hakata tegema pugide parandusi Aa, on võimalik teha juurdearendusi, sest sul tegelikult on niivõrd palju nagu sellist infot. Vaata, mida sa saad talle background ina anda, et saab väga kiirelt kätte. Ja
Õpetaja: et. Okei, mis siin toimub? Mis on kogu selle projekti värk? Vaata, mis on siin konkreetsetes kohtades, mis kuskil on tehtud, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Ise saad viidata ja siis juurde niimoodi teha. Pluss nagu ma ütlen ka, et sa kogu aeg hakkad süsteemselt leidma igast uusi nurki. Vaata, et. Oot, tegelikult. Ma saan ka niimoodi tööd teha. Vaata, et ma ise ka. Nagu siin paari projekti käigus olen täiesti Nagu erinevaid lähenemisi proovinud
Õpetaja: Ja üritad nagu aru saada. Vaata, milline work. Noh, tänapäeval sa muud ei loegi. Vaata, work, flow ja work flow, Ja kuidas agent aitab? Minu Work flow ga. Vaata, et mida iganes teed, siis mitte. Arendus. Vaata
Õpetaja: Kõik need teised asjad ka. Vaata, et Sa tood oma töövoogu, Tood Ai endale abiliseks, on ju? Nüüd ongi küsimus, et kuidas sina integreerid selle nagu enda nagu töö, nagu voogu Meile kõigile meeldib kuidagi töötada. Vaata, et mul on mingid erinevad stiilid. Kuidas nad lähenevad asjadele teevad, onju? Ja ja kuidas, nagu seda nagu endale enda töövoogu igal pool, saada. Et See ongi üks paras nuputamine. On ju, et ühtepidi või teistpidi aja jooksul hakkad aru saama, vaata. Mis Töötab sinu ja
Õpetaja: jaoks või mitte, Onju,
Õpetaja: et mina, nagu õpetan teile nagu ühte Nagu potentsiaalset töövoogu, mida ma ütlen, et proovige, vaadake, Kuidas see toimib, onju
Õpetaja: Lähete? Siit kursuselt Ära Vaata, Noh, siis on see koht. Vaata, kus te saate ka hakata. Võibolla proovima mingeid huvitavat Projekti on ju pigem. Saab see olema nagu. Ee, teil siis natukene rohkem. Niukene, vaata, et ei ole. Noh, alguses muidugi võiks ka teha käsitsi. Vaata, et nagu kinnistada endale kas neid oskusi asju, onju?
Õpetaja: See oleks nagu eriti ideaalne. Aga mingi hetk ka. Miks mitte Vaata Davai, et ongi mingi lahe mõte, mida teha on ju? Teen endale. Mingi. Moki. Teen endale mingi projekti. Mõtlen neid. Asju Vaata läbi ja jupi kaupa. Hakkan seda tegema ja on võimalik tegelikult saavutada päris
Õpetaja: toimiv süsteem töö. Jätkusuutlik ka, aga lähme edasi. Ee, ärme jää siia kinni Vaja siis ee teha.
Õpetaja: Kust nüüd arendus on olemas? Mis arendus aru on olemas. Mis on siis järgmiseks?
Õpetaja: Räägitakse, et tuleb mingi teenus luua, mis see meile tähendab kakskümmend asja
Õpetaja: kuskile Kontrollerisse võiks minna Backendi lahti.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis meil täna siin hetkel on. Kontrollerite all on meil Ee City Controller ja on siin. On Ee Locations. Mis mõtted siin on?
Õpetaja: Aga Atm Controller oleks väga geneeriline, et mis sa Htm Controller et siin on Atm Location. Kas äkki ongi meil ka pangaautomaadid? Automaadid, kui sellised füüsilised objektid.
Õpetaja: Võibolla kui tahad nagu päris niiöelda asju päris automaate hooldada, lisada neid süsteemi. Näiteks neil on mingid omad ja asjad. Et see oli ikkagi neeriline Atm kontroller. Sa võtad võimaluse Ära vaata, et üks Hetk ongi vaja Atm kontrollerit, Aga see ei ole siin Atm, Controller, vaid see on.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: nüüd siin on natukene maitse asi. Vaata, on See, et kas teha natukene pikemalt või lühemalt. Mina teeks isegi lühemalt, et kui me teeme Locations Controller is, meil on klassi nimi mis on lühem, aga siin on jälle konks.
Õpetaja: Aga nagu kui meil tulevad mingisugused aadressid või asjad? Näiteks, et äkki hiljem tahame kuidagi aadressi võidate Location.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis on nagu on juba kinni. Vaata, Location Control. Seal on alati nagu mõttekoht. Natukene, aga alati saab hiljem refaktureerida. Vaata Onju Täna on see ongi koodivõlu. Vaata, refaktureerimine. Ümbermuutmine on ju täna. Me arvame, et noh,
Õpetaja: Locations Controller võiks sobida. Kunagi Hiljem Tahame teie uut asja juurde avastame, et Kurat, see asi on kinni. No mine refaktoreeri. Ära. Vaata, kui tol hetkel ei olnud vaja on ju Aga see ei tähenda, et ei võiks mõelda.
Õpetaja: See tähenda, kui sul on süsteem, Greenfield. Aga sa oled juba ära planeerinud nagu mingid erinevad asjad, kui Seal on pärast juttu lihtsalt mingi aadress kui Entity. Noh, sa tead, et. Okei, saan Location It siin kasutada ja pärast hiljem on nagu Aadressil Ongi adress. Controller või
Õpetaja: Mida iganes onju, et natukene saab nagu ette mõelda aga liigselt ei pea muretsema, et kõiki asju on võimalik alati hiljem muutuda.
Õpetaja: No mina pakuks, et ee. Teeks. Aa, pigem Location Controller.
Õpetaja: Teeme uue ka kohe niikuinii. See Lõpuks nii läheb. Mis me Seal ikka. Tõstame siis
Õpetaja: jah. Jaa, no, siin isegi saaks mõelda ka, et saaks ka Atm Location Package võib olla Atm Location Ee pikemalt, Aga no jällegi pigem üritaks võimalikult klassi nime nagu lähedal seda hoida
Õpetaja: siia sisse. Klass Location Aa, Valle.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui see klass on olemas, Mis võiks kohe ära teha?
Õpetaja: Rest Controller Ät rest. Controller, mis veel?
Õpetaja: Okei, küsin ka. Vaata ikka, mis sa meile näiteks Ühe asjana, mis Visuaalselt ka. Tuli siia nähtavale et igast ägedaid võimeid. Tuli Sellele klassile nagu hookus fookuse mõjul. Aga üks nendest on, see, et
Õpetaja: uba see on. Sellest tehakse komponent, vaid seda tehakse objekti. Seda hoitakse springkonteineris. Uba. Sellele viitab piim.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, mis? Veel Ja varem või hiljem meil On vaja niiöelda ee, mingi teise kastiga suhelda,
Õpetaja: et siis on meil vaja niukest konstruktorit ja kõik väljad, mis on markeeritud sõnaga.
Õpetaja: Nende Need lisatakse konstruktorisse põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Ja see siis on Dependent Injection. See on nagu see, et kuidas. Nagu selle muutuja taha tuleb niidikene mis viitab kuskile objektile, mis on kuskil mälus.
Õpetaja: See on nagu tehniline võte. See on see seal joonisel D I.
Õpetaja: Dependent Insection. See on niimoodi Siin töötab,
Õpetaja: Kuidas saame objekti muuta ja taha?
Õpetaja: No, rääkides sellest muutujast. Noh, kui
Õpetaja: me juba teame, et kui me tahaks suhelda mingisuguse teise ee kastiga,
Õpetaja: Mis see kast oleks meil? Esiteks, millega ma tahaks suhelda, Service. Aga mis service?
Õpetaja: Ma küsin,
Õpetaja: kui. Ja kui nüüd kirjutada nüüd natuke, teha natuke teistpidi. Vaata, et ee, et. Ee. Meil läheb seda vaja. Me võiksime Keyboard ära võtta. Kas Vastab tõele? Et siia peab niikuinii tulema, Sildikene,
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame suhelda järgmise kastiga. No aga teeme siis selle siidikese ära. Kirjutame Private.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis see sildikene Viitab? Siis klassile, millele Just rääkisime Location
Õpetaja: Service Nüüd me teeme jälle seda asja. Et ee, selline tehniline mõte, et me kirjutame või võibolla sellise sõna ka ära panna, kui ta ununeb.
Õpetaja: Jah, et ee. Soovime, et saaks järgmise kastiga rääkida. Muutuja nimi võiks olla sellel kontrolltöhik.
Õpetaja: Jah, enter, et tuleb see Semi kool on? Ei hakka sellist semi kooli end Otsima.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleme selle punase joone peale. See punane joon on see, et ei mind Keegi ei kasuta ja nii edasi. Aga pigem on suurem probleem. Täiesti punane asi
Õpetaja: tema Saab aru suure tähega algab muuta. Ilmselt sa viitad Klassile klassi pole.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siin vajutan.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ta ütleb. Et kuule, kas sa soovid, et Niukesse klassi loome? Vaata, et seda pole Ja soovin
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta küsib, et kuhu tahad seda panna.
Õpetaja: Service klass. Meil Ei, ole kontrolleri all.
Õpetaja: Paneme punkti ja vaatame, mis ta pakub meile.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuhu võiks ta minna?
Õpetaja: Jah, ma ei tea, selline struktuur võib. Mitu mitu kausta on Kontroller Service. See võib olla, täiesti, kuidas Projektis on nagu mindud suunaga. Ja ma olen näinud isegi ühes ettevõttes nagu erinevaid struktuure. Lihtsalt nagu, et kuidas on nii,
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib see Persisens kiht, mis ma ise alles tein sisse. Mul varasemalt meeldis natukene teistsugune. Niukene, Lhv lik, Ee, nagu ee jagamine.
Õpetaja: Aga mulle tegelikult on hakanud meeldima. Mida ma teen? No service kiht on muidugi alati minu jaoks natukene. See, et alati on küsimus, et
Õpetaja: kus kohas peaksid Ttod olema Service juures või nagu Controller I Middle. Ee, mina olen Tt d pannud ikkagi puhtalt. Ee, kontrollerile.
Õpetaja: Ee, sorry.
Õpetaja: Küsitakse, kas lisame Kitt I mis me vastame? Muidugi, muidugi.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks siin nüüd kohe kõik Ära teha?
Õpetaja: Kurmist ja Ad Service, et siin on teenustüüpi klass,
Õpetaja: Mis Erilise võime. Me saime siin paljude võimede seas jällegi Uba alaline liige.
Õpetaja: See objekt on meil kuskil mälus olemas.
Õpetaja: Mis veel samamoodi et varem Või hiljem mingi repositori või mapperiga. Suhtleme. Ee, siis Allars. Ei, ee, kõik.
Õpetaja: Miks mitte?
Õpetaja: No Ta saavutaks sama tulemuse, aga ka enda nagu Jah,
Õpetaja: Äkki tuleb see mingi väli veel juurde. Mis meil. Mis Mingisugune objekt tuleb siia juurde. Mida, no teoreetiliselt. See on nagu teoreetiline jutt, Mida, mida me Springilt ei tahagi saada? Vaata ja siis on küsimus, et kuidas me selle saame. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kui on, siis ongi kõik Väljad, mis siia tulevad, siis muud konstruktorit. Ee, sellel programm ütleme programmis pole. Ja siis on nagu põhimõtteliselt. Ee, Spring on sundseisus. Vaata, et Ta peab piinobjektid kõikidele leidma.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mingi klass on, millest ei ole piinobjekti,
Õpetaja: et ma nagu näen, et see peaks ikkagi olema. Konstruktor,
Õpetaja: Ee, aga meil meie Niiöelda selles projektinäites seda nagu seda olukorda nagu ei tule. Vaata, ee. Niiöelda mida ma just kirjeldasin, et äkki on Veel mingi väli ja mingi klass. Nüüd, kui siin oleme, kõik kenasti lõpule saanud, siin meil rohkem midagi teha pole. Soovitame siin Control B, Miks ma soovitan Control B.
Õpetaja: Kõik kohad, kus on seda klassi viidatud. Tahaks äkki sinna minna.
Õpetaja: Nüüd? Tema pakub, et Ee kontroller klassis. Ta Näeb Real kolm. Kus on import ja kuskil. Ee, real üksteist. Private Final Location Service Location Service. Loomulikult tahaks sinna minna.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, mulle Tõstetakse pakkund. Vaata, kuidas Location Servis on. Juba Md failis mainitud vä. Huvitav, Ee, ma parem.
Õpetaja: Nii et kui sa lähed sinna
Õpetaja: ja siis Vajutan praegu. Vajutan Settings vä.
Õpetaja: Loen teil lahti. Nii oih, sorry. Nii, Control. Siit võetan nii.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga tasub see maha panna. Niikuinii onju? Vaatame, mis siis on. No igal juhul, kas siis töötab teil?
Õpetaja: Jah, aa, see saab olema mingi chat I küsimus. Aga kui keegi selle teada saab.
Õpetaja: Ei,
Õpetaja: muidu sa kukuks lihtsalt siia. Vaata, näed siia sellele reale kolm. Siis. Lihtsalt, et tulla nagu koodibaasi tagasi, pead nagu tulema alla. Kui kukuks siia, siis siin on juba shift enter ja juba saab nagu toimetada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mul on nagu põhimõtteliselt väikene eeltöö on tehtud, Aga niimoodi ülevalt alla. No mina teeks niimoodi. Vot täpselt niimoodi. Ma ei. Me ei viitsi minna. Mingi
Õpetaja: lihtsalt. Ee, keyboard. Keyboard.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me oleme siin. Kus me siis hakkame defineerima Seda teenust
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja mingi uus meetod luua Kett Atm Locations rajale, millest alustan. Räägime meetodi struktuurist. Nimetage neid struktuuri Osasid, millest alustame.
Õpetaja: Nähtavus lätas, on Public Mixed Public ja
Õpetaja: et teised seda näeksid, ja saaksid seda käivitada ja nii Nagu Triin ütles, et dispetšer saaks seda käivitada, Sest me ise seda kohta kuskil kuskilt ühtegi koodirida. Meile ei tule
Õpetaja: ee. Peale. Nähtavust on
Õpetaja: Tagastatav tüüp. Hetkel on see. Me paneme alati voida, et nagu tegeleda hiljem. Nüüd on vaja nime juurde minna.
Õpetaja: Mis see nimi võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Ja Fine, nagu. Vaata, sa, tead et sa tahaks jätta selle keti tõesti nendesse kohtadesse, kus nagu, tõesti, nagu, ütleme, et, noh, on olemas Nagu on, ju,
Õpetaja: et, ee jätaks selle. Ee, ma proovin meeles hoida, kui repositorisse jõuame. Seekord, et ma näitaks seda seda, et pole seda mina välja mõelnud. Find Atm Locations. Aga tegelikult, kui meil on Location Controller,
Õpetaja: Aga see meetodi nimi võib isegi olla
Õpetaja: ee, et mis meid Kõige rohkem kõnetab
Õpetaja: lihtsalt see sõna. Atm on siin olemas. Vaata, las ta olla
Õpetaja: võiks olla ka Find Location see oleks ka täiesti Okei, Mis nüüd edasi?
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd on meil meetod Hall. Keegi välja ei kutsu.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd edasi peaks tegema?
Õpetaja: Sobib.
Õpetaja: Peaks sa ikkagi tegelema Eelkõige, Sest et siin on nagu see, et see on Hall hall. Keegi kunagi seda käivitanud, et seda hoola ei tee, miks me
Õpetaja: siin Toimetame, Onju, et keegi käivitab seda, kes ei peaks seda käivitama.
Õpetaja: Kes seda meetodit peaks välja kutsuma?
Õpetaja: Noh, need tavalised ee, vastajad võivad mitte vastata, vaid vastab keegi teine. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Küsin Eveli käest. Kui ta seal niimoodi siin ees istub meil ise ta selle koha valis, eksole?
Õpetaja: Mis ma nüüd järgmisena võiks teha. Vaata, et keegi seda ei käivita. Ta on hall. Keegi nagu ei kasuta,
Õpetaja: aga meil on vaja et see Meetod käivituks teatud hetkel teatud hetkel, kui tuleb sisse siuke sõnum,
Õpetaja: mis me teeme, ei tea nõus.
Õpetaja: Palun palun näidakene mind.
Õpetaja: No hea küll, usual suspecks, et meil on vaja see kaardistus peale panna. Noh, kui vaadata seda pilti ka ees,
Õpetaja: kui vaadata seda kogu pilti, et on meil mingi Controller. Klassi nimi
Õpetaja: on Meil Ee annutatsioon seal pildi peal. Rest Controller. On meil mingi meetod sõna otseses mõttes seal pildi peal Ja on tema peal markeeritud. Noh, natuke lühemal. Vormil
Õpetaja: on kaardistus. Vaata, kui tuleb sisse sõnum, siis käivituse kui ma kirjutan siia, et kui Tuleb sisse kett, sõnum
Õpetaja: kaardistusega. Valdkriips Aa, appi, appi.
Õpetaja: Aa, kas räägin appi? Loo ära või räägi ei?
Õpetaja: Ee kunagi naisega. Käisime seal kuskil Seal endla kandis seal kristiine kõrval Mingi tänav, mis jookseb sealt kõrvalt. Mitte See peatänav. Ja tule meelde, mis selle nimi, on
Õpetaja: kui minna Nagu parklasse kaine. Mis seal taga on? Vaata paremalt poolt. Mitte vasakult poolt. Kuskilt seal. Mingi. Seal on mingi mingi grill, mingi armeenia grill Ja mingid asjad seal lähedal on. Oled seal naisega mööda teisel pool teed Ja siis ühel pool teed oli mingi naine oma mehega nagu Rämedalt tülitses.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ta oli.
Õpetaja: Tulge appi appi ja siis naine vaatas mulle otsa. Vaata, nagu et teiselt poolt teed
Õpetaja: Mõtlesin, ma ei tea kappi. Tulge kappi.
Õpetaja: Ee, üks. Mu sõber kunagi õpetas tegelikult seda, et, ee, Noh, seal ei olnud mingit nagu niukest, et peksaks või midagi. Vaata, pigem oli niimoodi veits nagu oli, onju?
Õpetaja: Ära topi oma nina igale poole. Mida sa ei tea? Sa võid politsei kutsuda, kui tahad või mida iganes. Sa. Sa ei tea mitte midagi sellest olukorrast sündmusest, mis seal suundib,
Õpetaja: et, ee, seda ütles ka mu sõber alati Aga Ta põhimõtteliselt ütles, et niuksed olukorrad tasub pigem kõrvale jääda, sest lõpuks see lõppeb niimoodi. Et sa, saad ise kolki selle sama naise Ja mehe käest.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee, ei olnud seal midagi. Aga appi. Ta oli nii naljakas nagu.
Õpetaja: Olge kapi, ei tule kappi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui Meil on see rada olemas. Näete, läks siniseks. See asi.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma nagu vaataksin kontorit B, et, noh, kes mind välja kutsub, siis Ta ütleb, et Fund, et
Õpetaja: Sinine annab märku, et keegi mind käivitab ja kutsub välja.
Õpetaja: No samamoodi Praegu siin keegi ei kasuta,
Õpetaja: aga see ongi lihtsalt ideeliselt. See nüüd saab keegi käivitada ja käivitab. Kui vaja saab olema objekt sellest klassist
Õpetaja: ta käivitab selle meetodi siis, kui tuleb Sisse, kett, sõnum üks urliga.
Õpetaja: Nii, noh, see osa nagu mul siin Highlight It on Kind a covered
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleks vaja sellest request parameetrist, Nagu mõelda, et sisse võtab teenus parameetri nimega City Id.
Õpetaja: No mis mõtted on siis
Õpetaja: niimoodi? Me peame selle asja tegema, et meile tuleb sisse. Väärtus City Id. Olgu, see number üks, kaks, kolm, neli, null. Mis iganes me peame sellega siis need Location Id üles otsima. Mis, Mis selle City ideele kuuluvad, siis?
Õpetaja: Noh, see meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi, mis me peame tegema
Õpetaja: Aivar ja Triin ei vasta. Keelud on peal.
Õpetaja: Ja Fred ka.
Õpetaja: No hea küll, Jaanus. Mis siin tegema peaks Sa niikuinii tead seda vastust
Õpetaja: Siin on see asi, et väljaspool.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma oot teenus ütleb? Vaata, et teenus võtab sisse
Õpetaja: Request parameetri nimega City Id. Mõte on see Vaata, et meie Teenus peab tagama, taga tagastama Location Id, mis kuuluvad konkreetsele Nii öelda linnale või siis kõik niiöelda Asukohad, onju?
Õpetaja: Mõte on see, et ee, Kui tuleb sõnum sisse City Id väärtusega. Null,
Õpetaja: või kaks või midagi muud. Vaata, meil on vaja nagu seda nulli,
Õpetaja: Ühte kahte, kolme, või Midagi Xi mis iganes muud, Sest et meil on vaja sellega nüüd koolist.
Õpetaja: Jah, vot seda tead seda Ma mõtlesingi,
Õpetaja: et seal ma mõtlesingi Nagu Step by Step minnes, et vastab tõele Vaata, et meil on vaja siin selles tegevuses mingisugust väärtust
Õpetaja: tuleb sisse.
Õpetaja: See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust tööd ega mütsi. Me peame
Õpetaja: tekitama sellel meetodil selle võimaluse, et siia on võimalik midagi sisse anda ja siin on võimalik toimetada.
Õpetaja: Ja parameeter ongi just see,
Õpetaja: mis on see meetod, kus tema peaks teadma midagi, Et kuskil tuleb point, on see, et me peame Konkreetse asukoha. Konkreetse linna asukohad. Ära tooma. Aga See see informatsioon meile peab tulema kuidagi sisse.
Õpetaja: Jah, võta ära kogu kõik need annopatsioonid ja asjad
Õpetaja: Kui sina soovid niiöelda käivitada mingisugust meetodit mingisuguse tegevusega. Soovid sinna mingit infot kaasa anda, siis sa pead tegema selle jaoks
Õpetaja: parameeter sildikese
Õpetaja: Onju integare.
Õpetaja: Mis veel, Id?
Õpetaja: Ee, sis. Sisse tuleb. City Id. Jah, et linna väärtus tuleb. City Id. Kas Nüüd vastab tõele, et saaks käivitada seda meetodit ja ta saaks meile ka midagi kaasa anda. Juhul kui ta seda tahaks
Õpetaja: Nüüd idee järgi on olemas, aga nüüd ei Tea, et mis asi see nagu peaks tema jaoks olema. Et mis asi on see request padi on? See on see ee request parameeter. Ta Ei tea.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi see, et me, tahame teda aidata, Öelda talle, et
Õpetaja: et see asi saab olema raja. Nimeline parameeter ehk Request Param Rp.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta teab, et tema ootab kainda sisse niukest Urli, kus on City Id Võrdub mingi väärtus.
Õpetaja: See on küsimärk. Vaat mõte on Nagu see Sisse tuleb mingisugune väärtus
Õpetaja: suht. Sõnum tuleb selline. Tema Nüüd teab, et kui tuleb niuke sõnum siis ta vaatab, ahhaa me Oleme ära defineerinud et me ootamegi niukest nimelist parameetrit nagu City Id,
Õpetaja: Siis tema teab selle sõnumi puhul, et tema tuleb, võtab selle numbri Number üks näiteks
Õpetaja: paneb selle muutuja sisse. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: No kui ei saa. Ee, vaatame pärast seda vägedest Me saame põhimõtteliselt seda kohe proovida ka. Ma panen korra. See on vaatamise koht Korraks. Ma panen returnima
Õpetaja: seda Sama City Id väärtust korra siin. Ka, siis, et
Õpetaja: kas Ta tagastab. Panen korra käima,
Õpetaja: et tema lihtsalt annab mulle vastuseks selle sama väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Ma panen teistmoodi. Tegelikult ta meelde. Jah, panen hoopis seda, et otsime ots. Otsin linnad, otsin asukohad.
Õpetaja: On ka omad. I asukohad
Õpetaja: ja pagerid kohe käia.
Õpetaja: Break Point I maha. Siin Mingi varasemast on jäänud. Olen midagi näidanud. Pluss dring on koguaeg sees. Vaata,
Õpetaja: käivitas ja käivitanud.
Õpetaja: Ee, vist kohe on käivitanud.
Õpetaja: Teen lahti See vägeri
Õpetaja: Ee vastab tõele, et tegemist on kettesõnumiga.
Õpetaja: And Get kõik Sõnumid, mis lähevad Browser I Urlilt on
Õpetaja: on kett. Sõnumil on okei, ee võtab sisse City Id. Ma panen selle City Id väärtuseks. Näiteks null
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema saatis sõnumi meie serverile, mis on hetkel Back end Atm Locations on
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd pea. Selline sõnum läheb teele. Vaata, Unustage need kastid asjad ära. City Id väärtusega null. Me praegult Siis saime selle kinni ja öeldakse Otsin pangaautomaati asukohta. City Id Ga null kohta. Vaata teksti. Mõte Nüüd ongi see, et saaksite aru, et,
Õpetaja: ee, me tahamegi käivitada mingit teenust,
Õpetaja: See, et mis teenus käivitatakse, otsustatakse ära sellega, et see on kett ja selline urm,
Õpetaja: aga kaasa läheb lihtsalt informatsiooni selleks tegevuseks,
Õpetaja: kui ma Tahaks veel midagi panna. Ma saaks siia panna ja saada näiteks. Mina ei tea. Location Id. Ma ei tea, miks see ei saa olla isegi olemas. Aga näiteks
Õpetaja: Ja ma ei teaidi võrdub.
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin saate sõnum kui ma praegu selle käivitan. Mul muidugi ei ole õrna aimu Mis nüüd juhtub?
Õpetaja: Ee, ta selle defineeri võtab selle, et sai kogu selle sõnumi Vastab. Tõele.
Õpetaja: Tema Sai kogu selle sõnumi, et Ee, Null Location Id. Üks user Id. No ma panen siis mingi, kaks, et oleks kõik erinevad. Numbrid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see sõnum lähebki temale. Tema teab lihtsalt Ket
Õpetaja: hull. Näed, Hurl lõppeb ära. Kus tuleb küsimärk? Tema teab, et mõeldakse seda teenust,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd tema teab, et mina olen defineerinud siin programmiliselt selle meetodi, Et Minul on võimalik anda mingisugust väärtust. City Id.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, et sa otsi nimeline parameeter sealt tekstist, kus see asub, on isegi ülisavi. Ma võin näiteks panna selle kõige viimaseks.
Õpetaja: No ma proovin mingi uue numbri, nagu ma ei tea üheksa tuleb üheksa
Õpetaja: Kuidas tema teab, et võtab kogu selle sõnumi pilvasteks nagu. Hei, get sõnum. Mm, get. Sõnum. Vaatan oma kaardistusi.
Õpetaja: Kas mul on? Jah, on Küll Niukene kaardistus on olemas. Ee, see kuulub Location Controller Klassi ja käivitama peab Locations meetodi. Aga tal on ka informatsioon. Programmeerija on andnud märku, et. Kuule, vaata. Äkki äkki seal sõnumis on imeline parameeter.
Õpetaja: Kui sa leiad selle. Kui sa käivitad selle meetodi, siis ole hea, pane see siia.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis juhtub. Kui ma võtan selle, ära,
Õpetaja: siis ju ei ole midagi anda. Kas ta on all?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta juba ütleb. Vaata, City City parameeter on parameeter, Aga sõnumis seda polnud. Ta raja tundis ära.
Õpetaja: Ta sai aru, mida? Mis meie eel eesmärk oli, meie Eesmärk oli käivitada see sõnum, Aga nüüd ta ei vasta enam nõuetele.
Õpetaja: See on rekoer. No selle saab ka opsionäriks teha ja sulud juurde panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus on sulud olemasolud?
Õpetaja: Näe, ma saan kirjutada sellise asja siia sisse. Mis see tähendab?
Õpetaja: See tähendab, et see City It võib olla, aga ei pea. Olema Kui on, siis seda saab kasutada. Kui ei ole, siis ilmselt on all vabakuks.
Õpetaja: Ma saan proovida, saadan selle, Panen must järve käima kinni.
Õpetaja: Valesti pakendi käima.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis seekord tuleb, Sest et ta ei ole enam nõutud.
Õpetaja: See seadistus kehtib selle asja Kohta Samamoodi nagu et mis iganes annutatsioonile päris koodirida tuleb selle kohta. Annutatsioon kehtib.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes arnotatsioon on, ta kehtib selle koodirea kohta, millega Ta on seotud.
Õpetaja: Saadan selle sama sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Ta töötab, aga ta Ei, Anna viga, sest et nüüd, ma olen ära defineerinud, et see ei ole nõutud. Vaikimisi on.
Õpetaja: On kellegil küsimusi selle kohta, et kuidas asi töötab?
Õpetaja: Platsi served teab, et on kettsõnum selline rada,
Õpetaja: Siis ta peaks Proovima käivitada seda meetodit
Õpetaja: Aga kui näiteks. Kui ma võtan selle ära, siis ta mõtleb, et tuleb Request Pod Ina vaikimisi see ka ei töötaks.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma ei markeeri ära. Mida ma mõtlen, et mis? See, et mis see City Id on? Meetodist on defineeritud,
Õpetaja: aga me ei ole öelnud. Noh, ta võib olla mingi Ime läbi töötab. Võibolla mingi ime läbi töötab, aga ma pakun, et
Õpetaja: ma panen korra niukse vigase sõnumi
Õpetaja: pane. Vaatame jälle Veel
Õpetaja: tuleb null, sest ta ei tea. Ta isegi ei tea, et ta peaks siit midagi otsima. Ta mõtleb, et Tuleb mingi Ee. Request Bodis, nagu onju? Aga lihtsalt numbriline väärtus. Näiteks, ma panen nüüd selle tagasi siia. Panen City Id
Õpetaja: City. Id on Sõnumis, mis läheb, kaasa on väärtus kaks.
Õpetaja: Okei, Nüüd Ta võttis ikkagi mingisuguse. Mingisuguse If, iga ta midagi kontrollides ja ta leidis, et
Õpetaja: ta ei tea, et see on nõutud. Ma ütlen, et sind kainlane, Kus see dispetšer annab? Endast parima.
Õpetaja: Vastavalt Springi programmeeritud niiöelda ee asjadele, et Kuidas ta seda mõistab? Aga loomulikult me alati peaksime kohe ära defineerima ka kooditasandil, et mis asi see on
Õpetaja: nüüd on kindel? Vaata, nüüd, See erinevus on ju Vaata, kui ma panen uuesti käima. Nüüd on see nõutud parameeter vaikimisi.
Õpetaja: Ma olen ära defineerinud, et mul tuleb nihukene asi,
Õpetaja: et see on vajalik. Heidispatsi on siis ta teab, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: ma pean. Ootame veel.
Õpetaja: Ütleb automaatselt saan vastuse.
Õpetaja: Spring ise vastab. Vaata, See on Onju. Ära on programmeeritud, et kui tuleb nihukene viga, tuleb detail instant status.
Õpetaja: See on Springis endas ära tehtud. Juba
Õpetaja: nõuab parameetrid City, Aga sõnumist pole.
Õpetaja: Paned selle Done City
Õpetaja: kohe on olemas.
Õpetaja: Okei? Ee, see oli see plaan. Ee, mina kasutan. Panen selle Void iks
Õpetaja: Ei ole midagi. Ee, meil hetkel siin tagastamas. Mis nüüd edasi tegime? Oleme siin nüüd selles esimeses kastis.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegime oma Action I ära Sõnum käivitub defineeritud head. Jaa,
Õpetaja: no. Me võime panna siia endale operation iga ära. Juba
Õpetaja: ma seekord võtan taskist Ee, mis seal kirjas on,
Õpetaja: Tagastab pangaautomaatide asukohta. Infot läheks. Ee, siia Ät Operation is summar Iks.
Õpetaja: Aga võiks juurde panna veel ka tõen selle juba siia uuele. Reale.
Õpetaja: Ee, võiks see alla panna Ka
Õpetaja: Description, mis on natuke pikem Selgitus.
Õpetaja: Koma on puudu. Ma mõtlesin, mis ta pakub Koma, on puudu, Description Ja siin võiks panna, et selgitav informatsioon.
Õpetaja: Kui City Id on null, siis tagastatakse kõik asukohad, sest muidu seda ei teaks.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui praegu see uuesti käima panna, siis. Ee, no nüüd on meil Missioon on ees, onju,
Õpetaja: et kujutage ette, et kui tarkvaraarendaja tuleb mingisugust teenust niiöelda Mudima
Õpetaja: ta loomulikult. Ta alustab seda kuskilt kontrollerist. Juhul kui tegemist on rest teenusega. Ee, mida tema peab hakkama putitama või Muutma,
Õpetaja: tuleb vaatab Seda siit Kõige alg hakkab pihta nagu raamatukaantest. Vaata, onju, see on tema jaoks nagu nüüd ta näeb ka, et kuidas see töötama peab, et mis see toimub üldse tagastab pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot.
Õpetaja: Kui City Id on null, siis tagastatakse kõik asukohad. Aa, okei, okei, okei, olen teadlik Saate ma lihtsalt aru.
Õpetaja: Kõik on koodis olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii see tekst võib teil ka praegu kuidas iganes jääda. Tulete järgi kunagi. Siis ee. Saate selle. Kätte. Aga minu mõte oli see, et te saaksite aru, et mille jaoks see on.
Õpetaja: Praegult ei ole siin selle Locationsi juures midagi Eriti tarka räägitud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et tagastab pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot. See on see summari
Õpetaja: detail. Description on. Kui City on null, siis tagastatakse Kõik asukohad tuled siia alla vaatad. Ahah City Id. Aa, Okei, okei, kui see on null. Noh, sa räägid mul Story onju
Õpetaja: hetkel ta tagastab mitte midagi tühjust. Ainult. Ee, status koodi. Kui kõik läheb hästi, see muutub.
Õpetaja: Siin On nüüd Action Sai otsa.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd teeme
Õpetaja: et selle käivitab dispatser kontroller. Klassi mõttes, nagu on see kõik, mis on nagu vaja, et
Õpetaja: et me oleme ära defineerinud sellise asja mida Siis, ee. Sissetuleva sõnumi peale käivitatakse. Nüüd on vaja, mida teha. Suunata. See tegevus
Õpetaja: kuhugi mujale, kuhu me tahame. Tahame selle tegevuse suunata kelnerpoisile, Onju,
Õpetaja: kuidas? Mis ma siis siin kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Tto St. On veel vara Rääkida
Õpetaja: ukse juurde me. Ei hakka kontrollerklassis pöörduma
Õpetaja: service. Klassi on vaja suunata. See tegevus vastab tõele, et meil on olemas see Location Service klass, Juba, mida me soovime, vastab tõele, et meil on olemas siin Sildikene mille abil me saame suhelda. Selle objektiga on nii
Õpetaja: et kui mina kirjutan siia väikeste tähtedega, mida
Õpetaja: Location Service siis ma saaksin nüüd Kuidas kutsuda välja meetodid
Õpetaja: punktiga. Aga point on see, et seal ei ole midagi. Veel.
Õpetaja: No see on Fine.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha niimoodi, et Me teeme sinna ühe meetodi. Mis saaks selle uue meetodi nimeks olema? Seal Service klassis
Õpetaja: sõna Otseses mõttes pildi peal. On Teil see nagu kirjas, et siis on see sama näide.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei ole niimoodi. Aga et kui me siin otsustasime, et me paneme selle tegevuse nimeks, see on. Aga nüüd me ise programmeerime, et et on meetod. No on see sama meetod.
Õpetaja: Control Shift enter. Siia ka. Panen selle ära.
Õpetaja: Kas Nüüd võiks selle meetodi sinna luua. See on töövõte, et me viitame meetodile. Ta saab aru, et see on meetod tänu nendele sulgudele, et Viitame meetodile. Ta saaks teha meile niukse meetodi sinna. Location Service Klassi nagu paremal pool on. Näha. Kas võiks vajutada? Ee, yes,
Õpetaja: võiks, aga. Jaa, aga vaadake, kui ta praegult selle meetodi teeks, on ju nüüd see meetod, mis seal Location Service klassis elab? Tema ei tea oma välisest elust, ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on siin öeldud, et kui City Id on nullsuse, tagastab kõik asukohad. Kui mitte, siis vastav asukoht On ju,
Õpetaja: et see Location Service antud hetkel praegu, Kui me selle meetodi defineeriks, tal ei oleks mitte mingisugust informatsiooni, mida ta tegelikult vajab Selles kontekstis
Õpetaja: ehk siis
Õpetaja: mõte on nagu, see, et City tuleb kuskilt Urli Seest niiöelda väärtusena sisse. Käivitab selle meetodi ja siia selle niiöelda Sildi taha jääb elama. Ta elab ja sureb. Kahjuks siin mujal. Teda ei ole. Nagu
Õpetaja: Mujal teda ei saa kasutada, siis on see, et Me peame tegelikult selle siin niiöelda kaasa andma.
Õpetaja: Siia, Kirjutan
Õpetaja: City Id. Vaadake nüüd, kui vajut It enter it. Ta näitab nüüd sinna. Location Service tuleb selline meetod.
Õpetaja: Find Datum Locations.
Õpetaja: Kus on Sildikene City Id ehk? Kes iganes seda meetodit käivitab, siis kaasa, peab minema väärtus.
Õpetaja: Noh, Nal saab ka muidugi minna. Vaata, teoreetiliselt
Õpetaja: nüüd on niimoodi, et see, mis on siin, see, on see kelner poiss, tema nüüd tegelikult ei ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi Aga ta teab, et kui see tegevus käivitatakse, siis on olemas siin mingisugune City Id väärtus, Millega tema saab midagi teha.
Õpetaja: See ongi vaja. Me kogu aeg kanname See programmeerimine. See on imel imelihtne. Meil on ee, tegevused, meetodid, meil on sisendväljund. See on sisend
Õpetaja: informatsioon Point ongi see, et me ei tahagi teha niukest ee meetodit, mis kogu aeg niiöelda teeb täpselt samasugust asja Ei, vastavalt sisendile. Ta teeb mingit asja.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei ole, niimoodi et Ta toob kogu aeg ära. Ainult pärnu, Näiteks Pärnu kogu aeg. No mis kasu meil sellest on, onju?
Õpetaja: Pärlocation It Pigem siin siin on näide Ei Vastava on see pärnu? On see Tallinn? On See kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: See tuleb dünaamiliselt nii.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, mis siis edasi?
Õpetaja: Mis sa mõtled siin?
Õpetaja: Mis meil nüüd oleks vaja? Mis see missioon Nüüd on siis,
Õpetaja: mis on? Mis see on tagastab pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot. No kust me selle info saame?
Õpetaja: Andme baasis. Ja nüüd siin taaskis Öeldakse ka täpsemalt. Ee, mis tabelid siin rolli mängivad? Öeldakse, et City Allocation tabel. No Vaatame neid City tabelit. Me just vaatasime. Me tegime Niukse teenuse Get Cities oli ju.
Õpetaja: Vaataks seda. Location it. Mis on location is on
Õpetaja: location is on. Siis näeme on noh, location it Ee, taaskis ei ole tegelikult mainitud
Õpetaja: ühte asja, mida ei olnud mainitud üldse tegelikult. No, tegelikult peaks olema see ka mainitud. Seal täpselt see Mõte ongi. Meie defineer. Siin on mõeldud Soft delete Põhimõtteliselt samamoodi. Näiteks, mis on siis see usertabel Ee
Õpetaja: nagu härra Priit Raspel juba tuhat aastat tagasi rääkis, rääkib ka, täna et igal asjal on oma algus ja lõpp. Nii oli ka Nõukogude Liidul,
Õpetaja: et siin on samamoodi, et Me võime defineerida süsteemi mingisuguse asukoha.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla mingid muud andmed, mis hakkavad viitama nendele konkreetsetele idele. Probleem on selles, et aga kui see Asi Nagu enam nagu ei peaks olema. Kui ma selle kustutan, ära, mis siis?
Õpetaja: Noh, seda Id D on äkki kuskil viidatud? Ma võin juba öelda, etterutates, et meil on niukene tabel, kus Location Id on viidatud. Üks, kaks ja kolm
Õpetaja: Location Itest on viidatud.
Õpetaja: Ma üritan seda siit ära päriselt kustutada. Igal asjal on oma algus ja lõpp. Noh, tahaks Nõukogude Liitu ära kustutada. No ära kustutamine Kahjuks ei ole võimalik, Siin ei ole ka võimalik, kui ma üritan vajutada. Ta ütleb, ee.
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb, et et see Tabel Id üks on viidatud tabelis Location Transaction Type, et keegi viitab sellele, et. Noh, mis saab? Aga ongi see, et selles see konksu ongi.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on nagu see, et saab teha niimoodi, et kui meie teenus otsib ainult neid Location eid lisaks selle City Le, kus on see staatus on A, kui see ei ole enam A.
Õpetaja: Saame öelda, et tema enam kuskil nagu ei esine.
Õpetaja: Nagu seal kohas, kus saab asukohti näidata ja teda näidata, aga Ta on andmebaasis tegelikult olemas.
Õpetaja: Noh, Soft Liit on selle asja. Nimi.
Õpetaja: Igal asjal on valguse lõpp.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen ka, et, noh, seal rasva Lõpetas niimoodi, et alati on lihtsalt kaks veergust start ja end. Vaata, et millel on ka omaette väärtus. Teinekord ongi niimoodi, et kui sa Tahad oma süsteemi niimoodi teha? Et keegi saab kuskile midagi lisada? Mingisugust uut asja Aga ta ei ole kohe niiöelda nähtav,
Õpetaja: on alates mingist Kuupäevast või kellaajast. Lausa isegi siis sul on vaja selle jaoks veergu. Kui te hakkate tegema. Oma andmebaasi mudeleid, me vaatame teie teie niiöelda Mokki Arutame seal mingeid asju siis vahel. Varem või hiljem tuleb see, mis ma ütlen, et et, ee, praegu. Teie andmebaaside mudel seda ei toeta.
Õpetaja: Noh, näiteks ongi. Asi, on see, et siin saad lisada mingi uue asja asukoha. Aga ta ei ole ennem nähtav kui see kuupäev, Näiteks kui plaan on selline. Ma tulen vaatan Tabelisse, on ju? Noh, kui me räägime kuupäevast, kas siin on veel kuupäev?
Õpetaja: Ei, ole
Õpetaja: Noh, Siis see, kuidas te mõtlesite, et kuidas teie kasutaja, nagu saab seal nagu asju teha. Andmebaasi mudeli poolt ei ole lihtsalt toetatud, kuna ei Ole kuupäeva, et sellist funktsionaalsust ei saa olla. Praegult näiteks, et Luisa uus asukoht, onju. Ja tahaksin seda, et mida iganes, nagu välja mõelda Vaata, ma plaanin, niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: et kasutaja saab lisada ja siis saab selle panna mingid staatusesse. Võibolla ise on ju ja saabki üldse panna, Et, noh, mis kuupäevast alates ootel maksab?
Õpetaja: Ee Pangast saab panna niimoodi. Mää. Määra otrumakset. Saad teha niimoodi, et sa, paned ära, et hei Tee ülekanne ja saad ära panna, et, ee. Kuule, saad ise minu eest välja. Sellel, kellel sellel kuupäeval?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui te juba praegu täna mõtlete? Vaata, et on nagu mingi kuupäev ja kellaaeg. Siis te arvate, kas seal Lhv. Kuskil kuskil tabelis on mingi veer mingi, või ma ei tea midagi Taolist, No, ilmselt peab olema
Õpetaja: sellepärast, kui kasutaja Frondis valib mingisuguse kuupäeva, siis kuskile. See info ju peab, siis ju nagu minema, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuskil ta peab olema. Ja kuskil siis peab olema mingisugune Aa asi siis, mis üle teatud intervalli vaatab? Põhimõtteliselt. Kas mul on Pangasüsteem. Kas peab saatma mingeid makseid meie süsteemist välja?
Õpetaja: On ju, et kas on mõni kasutaja, kellel praegult staatus on nagu niimoodi, et ta soovib ootel makse ja on mingisugune kuupäev. Kellaaeg Seal on ka ära märgitud, et ta pole veel nagu välja saadetud. Mingisugune tiker peab seal taustal olema. Vaata, mis vaatab kõiki.
Õpetaja: Ee, ootori makseid Ja kui saabub mingi hetk, vaata, mis nüüd vastab tingimustele, et see kuupäev kellaaeg on saabunud. Ta saadab selle ära ja muudab mingisuguse staatuse. Vaata, et. Noh, see on nüüd hand. See ei ole enam ootori makse, see on juba process või? Ma ei tea, mida iganes
Õpetaja: ma konkreetselt nüüd ei tea, kuidas sul see.
Õpetaja: Siis kui see. Noh, ütleme, ta on üheteistkümnes kümme. Kakskümmend Kümme, kolmkümmend. Makse. Väljapidamine peale. Tuleb
Õpetaja: ei no ta. Ei, kustuta ära ta process. Ib selle Makse nii nagu iga teine makse Käivitub mingi prosessori. Näiteks kui sa oma panga makse näiteks kliendile. Vaata, onju, kes on pangas. Ee, seal tikib see süsteem ülesse, et see ei maksa vaja Protsessida Käivitub Internal Payment processor.
Õpetaja: See Account sellele account. Ile see. Oli. Noh, mis iganes seal maksus on, ja siis vastavalt sellele protsessile. Vaata, nagu seal. See protsessor ise teeb kõik liigutused ära, mis vaja. Noh, see teoorias nii on,
Õpetaja: aga mõte on nagu see, Vaata, kuidas ta huviorbiiti satub ja kuidas üldse käivitatakse. Me saame süsteemis teha niimoodi. Et iga viie sekundi tagant käivitub mingi protsess näiteks või Igal kellaajal või mis iganes ee automaatselt käivitub. Aga andmete pealt, et protsess on ära programmeeritud. Et mine, vaata, kas on noortel makseid, mida Nüüd saab saata
Õpetaja: korja ülesse. Põhimõtteliselt kõik need maksed ja siis käivita mingisugune protsess, mis on ka koodilõiguna juba olemas. See sama koodilõik siis, Kui keegi kohe teeb makse,
Õpetaja: on ju näiteks kui mina. Nagu hakkaks kandma. Niipea, kui mina täidan. Ära kellegi andmed vaata, ja niipea, kui Frontend saadab sõnumi, et sellelt kontot sellele kontole. Ee, seal on süsteem, mis tuvastad. Kohe Ära vaata, et tegemist on meie enda panga Kliendiga
Õpetaja: käivitub see protsess,
Õpetaja: et see osa on ära programmeeritud. Niiöelda, et nagu ühe makse kohta. Aga kui me nüüd räägime seda, vaata, et mingi, Süsteem otsib ülesse. Mis kootel Maksad? Üle korjata. Ta kasutab täpselt seda sama loogikat taaskasutus. Vaata, see ongi see, kuskil on See koodilõik juba Ära programmeeritud. Seal on ainult vaja Põhimõtteliselt kahte osapoolt. Onju, et kellelt, kellele? Mis summa?
Õpetaja: Kõikide võimalike väljadega, mis seal siis nagu saaks ära panna. Protsess hakkab käima. Meil lihtsalt on vaja teada seda, et et taaskis. Tegelikult ei olnud staatust mitte kuidagi mainitud,
Õpetaja: aga tegelikult meie kontekstis. Vaata, kui me tahaks, et see Soft Eli töötaks,
Õpetaja: siis me peame ka seda vaatama. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: Praegult ei olegi võimalik, nagu kuidagi, et adminil Ei ole võimalik. Meil on niukene asi nagu, ee, asukoha kustutamine. Asukoha kustutamine ongi Taaskis on mainitud suhteliit.
Õpetaja: Et Noh, ei pärista ketta ära, Kas on mingi staatus? Kas need on mingi kuupäevad asjad? See kõik on arhitektuuriline. Valik Vahet pole, Vaata, kuidas selle. Teeb.
Õpetaja: See ei ole isegi tähtis. Aga meie plaan on nüüd see, et me peame hakkama liikuma selle location Tabeli suunas, sest et me peame leidma kõik Location Id
Õpetaja: vastavalt. City Id Le Kas konkreetse linna asukohad või siis? Kõik? Aga me peame staatust ka vaatama.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma olen siin Location Services,
Õpetaja: Siis nüüd me teeme jälle nagu niimoodi. Et me. Ei, me ei hakka. Siin on nagu see parem võte on see, et meil on vaja viidata. Nüüd
Õpetaja: on nii? Me. Me saame ainult seda asja teha läbi Location i Location. Jällegi, et see tuleks oma kataloogi alla panna
Õpetaja: See nagu nii, nagu useril on. User, Mapper, user. Repositori City on City Mapper City. Repository tuleb tegelikult sama kama
Õpetaja: Suures pildis.
Õpetaja: Paneme ta Siis eraldi kataloogi Package Location, et sellel entitel oma asukoht nii
Õpetaja: võibolla panna ka nüüd need ülejäänud. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus ka ära, et ee. Kogu aeg ununeb. New Package, Ma võin selle. Te ei pea. Kui te tulete varem või hiljem järgi, siis te Võibolla ei pea kaasatingimata tegema
Õpetaja: aga mis sul tähele vaja panna on see. Ärge hakake siin mingisugust jama korraldama mingit niukest jama, ärge tehke
Õpetaja: Mingit ee, niukest jama. Ärge tehke
Õpetaja: mingit. No see on lubatud. Aga tegelikult ei ole soovitatav tühike ammu ette. Mitte Niimoodi on kõige parem,
Õpetaja: Kui väga tahate, võite teha ka niimoodi. Aga Arvestage, et teil tuleb veel üks kataloog
Õpetaja: ja siis tehniliselt võttes ta läheb selle location I, sisse, nagu ma vajutan praegult, kus ta tuli.
Õpetaja: Mul ei tekkinud siia veel üks location punkt image, vaid läks location i sisse ja see on ka mõeldav. See on nagu grupeeritav. Näed mingi kõik location I asjad võivad ka enda tulla siia its. Okay, aga et niukest asja Võib, ka, aga mina eelkõige tahan öelda, nagu näidata ka seda. Kas see on väga okei? Mis ma nüüd teen? Ütlen New Package
Õpetaja: ma panengi.
Õpetaja: Noh, teda on tüütu lugeda, aga me ei hakka nagu siin, väga Ei taha neid väga palju neid katalooge tekitada
Õpetaja: ja ei taha ka tegelikult absoluutselt mingeid sidekriipse asju Kasutada, sest et see igal pool selle klassiga, mis siin sees tuleb ja see ei vasta konventsioonile enam.
Õpetaja: No location Ime stopiks. Selle siia sisse ostetakse juurde. Ee location trans Action Type
Õpetaja: jälle paneks. No mis a class. Ma tahtsin panna New Package päris on?
Õpetaja: Ei, näed, on pikki haru.
Õpetaja: Jah, profile. Profile meil tegelikult päriselt. Ee, ei ole realisatsioonis. Aga las ta siis olla.
Õpetaja: Profile Paneme New Package
Õpetaja: Raul me niikuinii. Ainult praegu kasutame seda Location It ennast, et selles mõttes ei ole tähtis kaasa tulla.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaasa teha Raul ja Transaction Type ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on siis, asi, mida? Kohe, kui teil on baasimudel olemas, teil tasuks teha kõik entiteed ja panna kõik oma ära ja siis alles hakata tiimina töötama nagu, ee. Lihtsalt. Sellepärast, et siis on vähem seda, et keegi kuskil tõstab midagi hiljem Ja tuleb Merch konflikte asju Nagu veidi vähem.
Õpetaja: See oleks Niukene asi, mida võiks kohe ära teha.
Õpetaja: Nii segam,
Õpetaja: kus meil see on olemas Tähendab, meil on Location oli juba ennem olemas tema muutus, onju? Ennem oli Persistance. Need on persistent Location
Õpetaja: Ee. Nüüd oleks vaja seda reposiitorit
Õpetaja: Ja lõpptulemus oleks see, et meil oleks siin Private Location Repositori repositori Ja siin all me kasutaksime seda. Location Repositor It lihtsalt, see, et Parem klõps New,
Õpetaja: et saaks põhimõtteliselt selle järgmise akna lahti. Me saame kogu selle asja palju lihtsamalt kui siin hakkame kirjutama, Location
Õpetaja: ja näete, Ta ütleb New. Ta ei viita mingi olemasoleva asjale.
Õpetaja: Ja ta teeb ülesse siia selle sildikese ka. Ära
Õpetaja: küsib, kuhu paket sisse, kui me siin aknast. Selle defineerime.
Õpetaja: Location Entity pealt tehakse Location repositor I. Kui ei ole valitud see,
Õpetaja: siis võime siis niiöelda võit siit valida ka Vahelduseks tulen, otsin Persistance ja Location, et on Okei,
Õpetaja: või tulen Kustutan siin ära ja kirjutan Location. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: see on mõte mis oli Service Servist. Vaata, pakkus. Praegu on ju Persistance punkt Location. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: kokkuvõttes ta teeb uue klassi.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, tegi siia muuta Tegi, tegi Uue faili tegi
Õpetaja: nüüd meie missioon. Find Outem Location läbi City Id.
Õpetaja: Võtta korra see location tabel lahti.
Õpetaja: Kui mina küsin teilt, et otsi Location City It järgi, siis kas meil võib olla midagi, mis meid aitab? Või peame midagi juurde tegema.
Õpetaja: Paring u jaoks. Mis te arvate, Miks,
Õpetaja: jah?
Õpetaja: Ei, Sa ei saa pöörduda, mitte kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, et kui me tahame nagu seda, vaata, et kas kas on Fine Bla Blabla Pai City Id Siis niukest meetodit pole olemas, et maksimum, mis on ongi
Õpetaja: selle järgi otsimine Või siis kas kõik või anonüümselt, Aga niipea, kui meil on mingi kriteerium, mida me soovime vaadata,
Õpetaja: mis on üks nendest veergudest, mis on meie enda loodud,
Õpetaja: kui see on juba garanteeritud, et ei ole midagi, mida saaks kasutada.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis tähendab, seda, et Ee ongi põhjust sinna. Relocation repositori klassi täitsa sisse minna,
Õpetaja: Näed, Location Repositor. Il on kõik need asjad, mis on Location Entity võtmes.
Õpetaja: Aga meie saame Extend ida ja teha midagi juurde.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Ee, mitu varianti kas lähed? Vajutad siit? Hakkad seda t vajutama. Vajutad siit neid Midagi
Õpetaja: Erinevad variandid. No teeme me siis selle jpa disaineri järgi Praegult,
Õpetaja: et see on küsimus. Vaata, et kas pannakse meetodi nime järgi kokku või pannakse query Järgi kumma, meie valime nüüd siin sõna Otseses mõttes me need selles konkreetses task Is Saame sellest väga palju Abi nameiga. Oleks seda
Õpetaja: ma ei teagi. Kas oleks, võimalik, kui selle Saame alati paika et query Või no. Tuled valid Siit vahet. Pole sama asi siis kas. Find Instance Find Collection mis. Meid? Huvitab
Õpetaja: collection Sest otsi asukohta siit.
Õpetaja: Noh, on ju üks objekt. Teine objekt.
Õpetaja: Mitut rida. Otsime Locations siis potentsiaalselt kõiki
Õpetaja: Find Collection. Topelt klõps tuleb see aken lahti.
Õpetaja: Atribuut On siin mingi monstrid Väikseks nagu. Aga teeme, et Aa, et otsime siis mingi asja järgi.
Õpetaja: No mis on see atribuut, Mille järgi peaks otsima
Õpetaja: City Id. Vaata, nüüd on nagu mugav asi. See on eriti mugav nagu vanasti. Lihtsalt selline asi oligi keeruline. Nagu Alguses oleks mul ka aru saada, kuidas või mis moodi. Tegelikult on see imelihtne, et me tahame teha niimoodi, et me tahame City Id abil otsida. Aga ärge unustage ära. Vaata, et me kõik asja vaatame. Location Entity mõttes
Õpetaja: Location entitation objektid, Id City Name number vatm status Long Itul
Õpetaja: City on eraldi objekt. City Entityst, kus on eraldi veerand ja nii edasi üldse Kutsha aitab meil ülimõnusalt nagu ee ise
Õpetaja: ee, vaadata. Nagu veel sügavamale. Me tahame seda otsida City Id Abil. Okei,
Õpetaja: aa siis. Mis võiks veel olla? Minu parameeter? See on pealt ära läinud. Meil on ju parameeter. Millegi järgi Otsime
Õpetaja: viis järgi. Otsime, et kui City Id võrdub ja. Ja Ignor Case, no siin antud juhul Isegi Ei, numbrite puhul See ei tööta niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis parameetri. Võiks ära panna, et seal selles koeris on nimelised parameetrid, mitte mingid positsioonid, Üks, kaks ja kolm. Aga nüüd on Iga kord. Iga kord, kui te hakkate mingit listi tagastama,
Õpetaja: siis peaks nüüd mõtlema ka järjekorra. Peale.
Õpetaja: Issand, kui tobe. Kas teil on ka sama kitsas asi või väga nõme?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nagu küsimus, On see, et iga kord, kui sa Otsid Kõiki ridu? Vaata siis Jah, praegult. Ma võin korgentselt panna. Ärge teie pange, et praegult. Võibolla on need asjad täpselt selles järjekorras, nagu ongi vaja.
Õpetaja: Siis, kui sa ma praegult ei ütleks, et järjest andmed selle veeru järgi. Või selle veeru järgi Vist selle veeru järgi või Selle järgi veeru järgi ma juba unustasin ära. Ka ühe asja tuleb praegu see siin ka meelde, Onju Jäi kuidagi tähelepanuta.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kuidas, nagu asju andmeid järjestada. Praegult nad võivad sobida, Kui vaatad, aga andmed hakkavad elama Oma elu.
Õpetaja: Tule kustutatakse. Lisatakse, et iga kord, kui sa Küsid mingit listi, siis sa peaksid korraks mõtlema, et
Õpetaja: kui ma mitte midagi ise ei ütle, siis nad tulevad selles järjekorras nagu asju on Lisatud
Õpetaja: nagu nende numbrite järgi on järjestus. Noh, kui sealt kaob midagi ära, Nad tulevad vaikimisen niimoodi, aga siis on vaja mõelda, et aga Kuidas ma soovin?
Õpetaja: Noh, seal on need erinevad variandid, et. Ee. Kas me nüüd vaikimise Näiteks, kui tulevad linnad seal ka ei pannud, siit, Seal unustasime üldse ära.
Õpetaja: Siis me kasutame
Õpetaja: meetodid, mis on juba sisse ehitatud. Antud hetkel tulevad kõik linnad selles järjekorras, nagu nad on lisatud See tegelikult on küsimus, et. Oota, aga kas tegelikult tahan nii? Äkki võiks tulla alfabeetiliselt linnale nimel,
Õpetaja: Kui te tahate mingit kui te tahate üldse niukest asja kontrollida. See on ka väikene trikk, mida ma praegu kohe ära õpetan. Kui te tahate jätta endale niukse võimaluse, et andmebaasis on üldse võimalik? Eriti kui nad on näiteks võibolla niimoodi, et te tahate ära defineerida, mis? Järjest? Asjad tulevad ise?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma toon nagu Näite.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kui me tegime näiteks Lhv S. Ee. Mingid admin leadest ehk siis veebilehekülg. Mida Ainult admiinid näevad ja igasugused kontoritöötajad said seal igasuguseid asju teha, eks? Raporteid jooksutada, teha mingeid toiminguid, tegeleda mingi probleemsete maksetega, mis on kuskil kinni jäänud ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: meil olid Oma tööriistad. Ja siis ongi see. Kui me tegime neile mingit funktsionaalsust juurde, siis tihtipeale need sealt kuskilt ritmehüüdest said nagu valida. Vaata, et ma Ei tea, jooksutas seda raportit ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Siis oli nagu nende poolt oli tegelikult nõue. Vaata, et nad tahtsid. Vaata, et kuidagi tulevad Mingi loogilises järjekorras. Aga
Õpetaja: customi järjekord? Vaata, et noh, see võiks olla peale seda
Õpetaja: ja see võiks olla enne seda ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: siis tähendab seda jällegi. Vaata, et kas see andmebaasi mudel toetab seda, et andmed ju, et ripmenüüandmed tulevad kuskilt andmebaasist. Kui me tahame Customi järjekorda,
Õpetaja: Siis kuidas ma saan? Ma ei saa tähestiku järjekorras name i järgi, et noh, mulle ei sobi nagu need asjad, võibolla mis seal tabelis on olemas, siis seal oli eraldi veel eraldi.
Õpetaja: Ja see on Niuke. Väga lihtne. Mingi üle üle saja. Lihtsalt oli seal väärtus, et sada Kakssada kolmsada, nelisada viissada kuussada, seitsesada. Selle järgi. Siis oli järjestatud. Vaata, et anna mulle need asjad.
Õpetaja: Kui sinule tuli mingi teenus juurde, et Sul oli vaja kuskile konkreetse vahemikku surada. See siis sa lihtsalt võtsid. Vaata, et noh, kui sa nägid, et üks on sada, teine on Kakssada.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tegid mingi uue asja juurde, siis sa vaatasid, millisesse vahemiku puhul ta peaks minema. Noh, panid siis mingi sada viiskümmend näiteks Täpselt kuskil keskele,
Õpetaja: on ju? Ja siis on nagu võimalus. Vaata, et kui tuleb veel nüüd mingisugune asi juurde, siis nagu nende numbritel, on Võimalik, ee siis järjestada sest me tahtsime, et rippenüüsse tulevad asjad täpselt sellises järjekorras, nagu meie tahame.
Õpetaja: Mitte mingit tähestiku järjekorras niukseid. Asju tuleb Mõelda jällegi. Vaata ka, et, ee, kuidas kasutaja mingisugust asju näeb. No, linnade puhul on ka Näiteks näide Näiteks mõtleme. Vaata, et kas me Tah, kas me lepime sellega, et tulevad kõik tähestiku järjekorras?
Õpetaja: Täiesti okei, olla.
Õpetaja: Eriti kui te kavatsete oma rippe nüüd teha niimoodi, et saab tähti ka toksida ja Search Ida, vaata näiteks. Noh, et Tallinn on seal kuskil allpool Või ma tahan, et Tallinn on kõige, esimene, aga Siis tuleb ju mõelda jälle. Vaata, et kuidas me selle saavutame. Frontis on ka muidugi võimalik igast asju ära teha, et otsi tallinn üles Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on ka, võimalik, et pärida andmed ja Frontis Võime uuesti töödelda Vaata, on ju? Aga võibolla tuleks see kohe Backendest. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: Kohe, aga kuidas. Kuidas me teeme niimoodi, et Ee, Tallinn tuleb esimesena Antud hetkel See ei ole kuidagi võimalik
Õpetaja: nagu ma Mõtlen nagu, et, ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, numbrid juhuslikult võivad kattuda.
Õpetaja: Aga niiöelda andmed liiguvad igatepidi, et et ma ütlen, need, on niuksed asjad, mida tuleb mõelda
Õpetaja: vastavalt vajadusele. No meie võiksime võibolla järjestedagi. Kuidas võiks järjestada need asjad siin?
Õpetaja: Ma panen esiteks selle repositori meetodi tagasi. Ee, mis oli query.
Õpetaja: Collection Esimese Panime paika onju, ja id Aga. Nüüd saame teada et, on veel üks asi
Õpetaja: üks Sisend on veel vaja vaadata
Õpetaja: Staatus. On ju, et taskis Seda ei olnud öeldud, aga tegelikult see nii mõeldud on Staatus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see järjekord, mille järgi võiks järjestada
Õpetaja: kuidas teil on mõtted. Ja te nüüd saate, aru, et seda järjestust saab siin mitu panna, et esimene järjestus tee mingi ühe parameetri alusel ja siis nüüd omakorda nende andmete sees saab järjestada veel asju.
Õpetaja: Aga miks sellepärast, et neid, tabel neid tabeleid näeb? Tavaline customer. Vaata, et miks nad Statuse järgi peaks. Mis see meile annab? Kõik ahad tulevad ennem ja teisi. Tegelikult ei taha üldse näidata. Ja
Õpetaja: aga järgmine filter on midagi Eraldi Teenust Mis filtrist me räägime? Taaskis pole seda. Vaata, meil on ainult üks filter. Vaata, City Id. Järjestus järjestuspoole taaskis öeldud. Tegelikult oleks See peakski olema öeldud
Õpetaja: Või Meil võib olla ka üldse Niukene. Ee, andmed. Kus see sisendina tuleb? Sisse, Vaata selle veeru järgi. Ja selle Veeru järgi
Õpetaja: olete näinud? Küll neid Vaata, saab igatepidi, nagu aitad mingi noolekesi. No mina tegin ka oma õppeprojektis. Tegin niimoodi et, et, ee, et Iga veel iga veelgi oli võimalik järjestada. Frontis on seda võimalik alati teha. Aga probleem on siis, kui kasutatakse teate, mis? Puchination on
Õpetaja: Kõik on koputavad. Mis asi see on? Hästi keel, et võin ära teha Oletame, et meil on andmebaasid. Ee,
Õpetaja: mingi mingit asja on sada rida. Lihtsalt kui ma mingi tabel. Mis iganes see on, mingi locations või mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus nagu seda. Vaata, et kas me Tahame sadat rida korraga kasta, veel näidata. Mis siis, kui iga selle juures on mingi pilt? Näiteks
Õpetaja: pilt on päris mahukas onju
Õpetaja: või võibolla Mahukas ja paremal juhul, kui see tabelis on, siis peaks olema pildid. Võiksid võibolla mingi välise platvormi või millega iganes kaudu võid, see võib olla Oleme annageeritud. Võibolla ei peakski ise neid andmeid iseendal hoidma. On ju võibolla vaja seda, et pildist on mitu versiooni suur pilt keskmine pilt.
Õpetaja: Mingi võibolla mobiilivaaded ja asjad. Võibolla need kutsuvad välja. Point on see, et. Vaata, kui me. No okei, kaugem sõidame, aga tuhat rida,
Õpetaja: Kas tuhat rida Soovime näidata, Ei soovi.
Õpetaja: Meie võimalus on kasutada niukest lähenemist kasutatakse. Mis on, niimoodi et siin on kaks parameetrit, et mitu Tükki mulle ei näita. Ma arvan. Näiteks, et näita mulle maksimaalselt kümmet rida
Õpetaja: nii. Kümne. Rea Kaupa kui on, ee kui. Meil, on sada rida. Päriselt andmebaasis. Mitu lehekülge tuleks Sellest,
Õpetaja: Kui need on? Teeme need lehekülgedeks. Näita ainult kümme korraga kümme tükki. On ju siis on, niimoodi, et siin on leheküljed. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis. Tead ikka, olete näinud niukseid asju, onju? Näita mulle kuni kolmkümmend tükki ja sa hakkad pensionidega minema näed. Okse asja
Õpetaja: ongi see, et vaata iga kord. Meil on vaja teada põhimõtteliselt, seda, et mida sa tahad. Anna mulle andmed City Id kohta. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: järjest ka. Kõik tähestiku järjekorras järjest ka nende järgi. Ja nüüd on nagu see See päik jääb paika, Anna Selle City Id järgi järjest ta andmed. Niimoodi kasvavad kahanevalt.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle kümme tükki ja siis põhimõtteliselt. Ütlen millisel, lehel ma olen et, kas Näiteks esimesed kümme järgmised kümme
Õpetaja: ja nüüd. Back end saab iga kord tegelikult selle sama pä saab uue päringu vaata kui. Kasutaja, klikib
Õpetaja: page Kaks, mis ta teeb? Ütleb. Palun anna mulle kümne kaupa page Kaks
Õpetaja: ja. Järjest just niimoodi ja. City Idee see. Põhimõtteliselt tuleb lisaparameetrid. Tuleb juurde, Ta teeb uuesti päringu ja ise leiab järgmise
Õpetaja: järgmise ka sisse Ehitatud pärast vaatama. Peame tegema natukene korda, kaks Kui me otsime need Sisse ehitatud meetodid võtavad ka. Ja me enda. Me objektid, mis me teeme? Nad saavad kahte niukest objekti sisse võtta. Üks on
Õpetaja: sort Object on see, et sa saad veeru nime järgi öelda.
Õpetaja: Järjest saab mulle praegult andmed selle
Õpetaja: veeru järgi Ja mis näide on,
Õpetaja: kasvab ja ka Nagu on mingi string. Siis on Abc mingid numbrid. Üks, kaks, kolm, kolm, kaks, üks. Kogu. See on üks objekti. Nagu sort objekti on võimalik alati sisse anda. Ja teine on ee. Page või Paging Sorting. Ma ei tea, mis selle objekti nimi on. See on siis see,
Õpetaja: Mitme kaupa me asju vaatame?
Õpetaja: See võib olla ee. Programmis fikseeritud, et ongi täpselt kümme sada mis. Iganes või no. Näiteks menüü olete näinud ikka seda, et näita mulle. Ee, kahekümne kaupa. Kuuekümne nelja kaupa saja kaupa ja midagi taolist. Noh, kui te niukest asja näete, siis kui Te mõtlete, et seal taust taustal toimetakse Java ja Spring pool. Siis te teate ka, et see, on see
Õpetaja: nii öelda? Objekt on sorteerimine, jõuame. Sorteerimine Ee frontend. Backend versus. Vaata siin. Kui on kasutatakse niukest lähenemist, siis frontend ei saa sortimist aa manageerida. Kui teil on selline Lahendus, mis lihtsalt annab kõik kõik read, mis on
Õpetaja: kohe pole. Kui palju neid seal on, On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Siis te tahate sorteerida lihtsalt Seal Javascriptis
Õpetaja: vajutad ühtepidi Massiivselt Ruttu Järjestab siis ühtepidi, vaid on teistpidi väga mugav. See töötab senimaani,
Õpetaja: kuni pole palju andmed, palju ridu. Kui on selline värk, siis ainult Backend saab seda sorteerimist ja järjestamist teha? Miks? Sest iga kord kui sina ütled, et mina anna mulle palun kõik asukohad järjest ka Tallinna kaupa. Aga ta siis peab näitama kümmet esimest aga. Back End tegeleb sellega
Õpetaja: et, siis sellisel kui, te tahaksite teha sorteerimist, Nagu et seal klikid peale üks või teine veer, siis sa pead tegelikult selle back end ehitama ja siis see tuleb hoopis sisendina sisse, et lisaks City Id Le tuleb veel Staffi.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: siis ma saan õigesti aru, et ee, andmebaasilt me pärime kõik andmed, Ee, Sorteerime need ee Id järgi, Aga need, ee, sorteerime ära. Just mitte Backendis, vaid andmebaasis.
Õpetaja: Me päringu saadamegi niimoodi, et anna mulle ainult need Read. Mäletate, kuidas see andmebaas töötab? Iga Jumala? Ta käib kõik read läbi ja ta lihtsalt. Otsustab True või False.
Õpetaja: Kas jääd peale või Jää peale, et seda me ei taha. Kõik, mis see see on. Kõik, mis on nagu niuke, et mis tegelikult tahaks pärida ja filtreerida ja toimetada. Mida saaks teha andmebaasis.
Õpetaja: Me tahame tingimata seal teha. Sellepärast Andmebaas on nii ülimalt ära optimeeritud.
Õpetaja: Disainitud. Vaata, et temast kiiremini midagi otsida. On programmiliselt pea. Võimatu, et ma pärin mingid andmed. Ja ma hakkan programmiliselt neid töötlema. Seda me teeme ka siis, kui selleks on vajadus.
Õpetaja: Või on mingi põhjus, miks me tahame seda teha? Vaata, et me teeme seda programmis, kui me saame seda teha niiöelda pigem nagu Aa,
Õpetaja: seal andmebaasis. Me eelistame alati seda seal. Igast järjestused, asjad. Kõik saab seal Ee, välja arvatud see, kui tegelikult hakkab asi nagu, väga, kuidagi äriloogikaks minema. Siis on nagu see, et me võibolla tõmbame pidurit.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et seal on alati igast argumente igast asjadest tuleb nagu kaaluda ja mõelda, onju? Aga suures pildis Igasuguste andmete pärimine, filtreerimine, järjestamine. See on puhtalt töö,
Õpetaja: Aga seda me praegu siin teeme. Ka
Õpetaja: mina Ütlen, et kui ee, otsime, siis teine atribuut on staatus. Rohkem pole, Aga nüüd on järjestus. On ju?
Õpetaja: No, minule tunduks kuidagi mõistlik vaata. Et kõigepealt toimub. Oletame, et on palju andmeid, et toimuks järjestamine linnade kaupa
Õpetaja: on ju Cityname järgi näiteks, aga siis veel lisaks õudsalt halb on siit vajutada.
Õpetaja: Võibolla ma pean selle fondi. Pean väiksemaks tegema. Siis läheb kõik muidugi väiksemaks. Võibolla see natukene Praegu Siin mängib Ee, järgmine Asi võiks olla siis ise näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh, tuleb seal mingi mustamäe prisma. M tähega sikupilli prisma on siis hiljem Vaata Onju Saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: et see on nagu, kes on. Ma ei tea, olete Excelis kunagi sorteerinud asju Seal on ka niimoodi, et klikid kõigele ühe peale sorteerid, Kõigepealt nagu ma ei tea kõik linnad ära. Aga sa vaatad, et Okei, Kõik linnad on. Kõik on linnade kaupa nii nagu sobib Tallinn, Tallinn Tallinn. Pärnu, pärnu, pärnu. Aga siis vaatad nagu mingid sekundaarsed andmed on nagu pudru ja kapsad,
Õpetaja: nagu mingi Jumala suvalise järjekorras, see ongi, et. Oot, oot. Kõigepealt linnad ja siis asukohanimed. Ja siis on nagu ilus silmale näha. Ja sa leiad kiirelt ülesse selle, mida sa vajad, No, mina nagu kujutaks ette seda nagu niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mis oli.
Õpetaja: Ee, viimane oli. Jah, ma ei saa väga näidatagi. Vaata, onju, et peab nüüd rääkima, et atribuudid olid meil Ee City Id
Õpetaja: ja and Staatus oli nii staatus. Ee, neid parameetreid mul nüüd jälle ununes ära. Pange see kindlad peale.
Õpetaja: Ja siin järjekord. Esmane järjestus on asending. On Cityname.
Õpetaja: Järgmine on.
Õpetaja: Oli lihtsalt Name Location name. Kui te. Kui te näete neid tabeleid. Mu esimene soovitus Alati on see, et pange kõigepealt kohe. Vaata need kinni.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma mõtlen, nagu kui te teete midagi, et et siin, et kui sa valid mingi Id või name, siis vaata. Sa võid eksida,
Õpetaja: et mina teen. Oota, Ma panen kinni. Ja kui mul on vaja alles. Siis ma lähen teen lahti ja otsin. Vaata, on ju, Sest arvesta ka, et see on. Ma ei saa siin nurgas Näete, Location. See kogu jutt käib läbi Entiti.
Õpetaja: Mis kutsel? Hambus oli,
Õpetaja: Entity? Et see see klass on tema informatsiooniks. See on see, mida siin kuvatakse. Näete, see on Camel Case
Õpetaja: number. Ftms. Andmebaasis ei ole Camel Case
Õpetaja: vaid on, et ta ei viita nendele asjadele tabeli mõttes, vaid läbi Entiti
Õpetaja: City ei ole. Siin on Kirjas City Id,
Õpetaja: sest andmebaasis ei ole niukest välja nagu City
Õpetaja: on juba. See on City Id.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on Jpa. Meil on niimoodi, et, ee, siin nendes klassides City asemel ei ole mingi Id vaid hoopis City objekt, mis on eraldi üks Rida City tabelist koos nende veergudega.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: mina pean selle Nam I valima, et üks on City Name ja teine on, No need ei jäägi. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Kas keegi näeb.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: ma võin korra proovida ühte asja, aga ma teeksin seda vahetunnil. Aa, võibolla vahetunni Võiks küll teha. Ee, vajutab. Vajutame, Okei?
Õpetaja: Tuli Kõigil mingi niukene rõve Monster
Õpetaja: meetodis. Mingi Underscore and status Order by Cities Underscore Saate aru praegult. Kui meil ei oleks seda query
Õpetaja: Siis, meie meetod oleks siukse nimega
Õpetaja: ja. Siis on nagu see et, kui sa kuskil servis siis, Hakkad nagu nägema ka veel seda. Vau,
Õpetaja: mis asja. Order? Order by City Name sending name.
Õpetaja: See ei ole isegi eskueeline lause. See on Mingi Väga kole asi. Vaata, sellepärast ongi see. Query. On see et, nüüd vaadake ma, korra kustutan selle ära kui, ma praegu võetakse et, Altinsert.
Õpetaja: Ta pakub, et Kuule, tahad ekstraktida. Ee, seda
Õpetaja: Tahad ekstraktida? Ee Koeri annotatsiooni selle meetodi nimest, A. Mis ta kaine ütleb Ja query And configer.
Õpetaja: Kui paljutada seda akent, siis Kutsha teeb niukse asja lahti. Vaata, mis, ta ütleb, et ekstrakti ee niiöelda language il query Ja Mis ta siin pakub? Short main
Õpetaja: thats the Whole idea. Kui tuleb annutatsioon peale, siis see annab meile selle võimaluse et me saame sellest asjast teha. Mingi Normaalse asja. Mingi find paar sõna ja kõik,
Õpetaja: et see on see koeri mõte. Ma ei tea, kas ma nüüd kommitti Tegin või ei teinud Just mitte. Ee, Kuskil on kood täitsa katki. Ma kustutanud selle siit ära, et katkist koodi ei commit iks
Õpetaja: Control Alth ka. Ei, see tuli Kolmkümmend üks oli Mul siin Control ka. Ee, Mis see on B? Seitse
Õpetaja: ja. Oih, Anna, Blokk on peal,
Õpetaja: ma Ei, ole vale nupu. Vale nupu. Aitan. Ee, P, Seitse work in progress. Üks
Õpetaja: No mitte ainult buss. Tõus pausi.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: aitäh just. Jah, teeme siis viisteist minutit. Ikka tegime pikalt.
Õpetaja: Üksteist on Viis
Õpetaja: ei saa. Äkki sa tuled ja. Ja, ee, teab ära kõik
Õpetaja: ait, ait, Ait ait. Aitäh Ja
Õpetaja: ei saa võib alustreerida.
Õpetaja: Ahah, okei. Aa. Ja peaks üldse panema. Aga
Õpetaja: rekordi ka. Vaata pausile pole mõtet seda paneme Ee, share, ime.
Õpetaja: Ee. Mis me nüüd saime? Põhimõtteliselt selle meetodi nüüd endale siia nina alla, mis ta tegelikult täpselt seda teeb? Vaatame, kuidas See Syntax käib. Ta ütleb põhimõtteliselt läbi. Entiti. Vaadake, Location on. See on päris koodirida. See ei ole mingisugune string, mis on mingi lause,
Õpetaja: Ütleks, et vali Tabelist Location. Edaspidi viitan sellele objektile, Kui L näete. See on Niukene lühiviis, nagu ka enda, nagu see on muutuja
Õpetaja: tagas ta mulle L. See tähendab seda, et ta tagastab tervet seda objekti. Niiöelda tervet ühte rida.
Õpetaja: Siis öeldakse, kus L. Punkt City punkt Id. Ta läheb nagu sügavamale. Vaadake, Location. Ise ju viitab
Õpetaja: City Leon City siin.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen siia City sisse, siis City S on niuksed Väljad on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui ma ütlen, et L. City, siis ta viitab Location I City peerule, Aga Id le, siis ta juba viitab tegelikult City objekti sisse. See on Entity on ju? Kui mugavalt. Ta. Nagu ise seda joint sinna sügavamale läheb, Me ei kirjuta siin mingit join ega midagi, aga taustal. Niiöelda vajalikul hetkel. See toimub.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis meile ei meeldi, on see, et esiteks see meetodi nimi ei meeldi meile.
Õpetaja: Mina küsin kõigepealt. Find What.
Õpetaja: Unustame selle pai ära. Vaata, et Mida me. Siit otsime. Mida me saame.
Õpetaja: Jah, ots. Tagastage Location Ite listi.
Õpetaja: Siis Seega võiks öelda, et Find
Õpetaja: Locations Escape iga see muu asi ära panna. Ma tahaks teha niukse üs üsna lihtsa konstrukt konstruktsiooni Senikaua kuni võimalik on see, et nüüd muutuja nimed
Õpetaja: defineerivad ära, et mille järgi me otsime.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb siin niimoodi. Et kuidas te, kuidas kutsa meile tegi, siis tema pani Id ja ta. Tegelikult, kui me vaatame seda. Id D nimi on Id, on ju et siin. Kus on See Id D viidatakse siin It järgi, et sisend, tuleb siit sellest muutujast. Minu küsimus, et mis Id see on?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd seda Olekski mõistlik siin ära muuta see. On asi mida, te oma töödes tihtipeale ei tee ja unustate nagu, kuidagi ära on ju on see et saate aru, kui kuskilt keegi kutsub seda meetodit selle tööriistaga välja
Õpetaja: siis tema näeb kohe, et Fine Locations ootab sisse integeri Id, aga Siis on küsimus, mis Id seda koodi ta ei näe. Vaata väljakutsumise koha pealt. Seda koodi ei näe. See Id ei ole kuigi kõnekas, Võiks lihtsalt ära muuta selle.
Õpetaja: Nüüd need abirattad parab, et senikaua, kuni see siin No teemegi näite, et siin ütleks, et on City Id
Õpetaja: Praegult see asi endiselt töötaks.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast tema ütleb siis, et et see asi on siin üleval. Nimeline parameeter Id.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me tahaksime seda abiratast ära kaotada. Ja Seda me tahame ära kaotada.
Õpetaja: Siis peab siin üleval. Kas siin üleval on kuskil viidatud City Id D siin on Id.
Õpetaja: Siin on staatus, aga ei viidata City Id.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kui me muudame ära selle ühes kohas, peame muutma teises kohas Hea tava. No ma võtan korra. Tagasi. On ju? Oleks isegi teha alati niimoodi, et tule muuda kõigepealt siin ära,
Õpetaja: It ja siis tuled Muudad siin ära,
Õpetaja: Kui teed niipidi, et siin muudad ära, siis tihtipeale ülemine ununeb ja siis tuleb rundtimeil. Tuleb viga,
Õpetaja: Kui neid enam Ei Kato abiratastest. Tahame lahti saada.
Õpetaja: Noh, sellest abiratast tahaks ka lahti saada, aga siin see nimi juba võikski nii jääda
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd vaatame, mis Siin otsitakse, et otsime mulle Location objekte. Kus City Id on? Id väärtus, mis tuleb siia sisse
Õpetaja: ja staatus on see, mis tuleb siit alt sisse ja siis ta ütleb Order Bye
Õpetaja: Location City City Name oma location name. Tegime niukse, asja,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult see ei ole kuigi keeruline. Natukene sellega siin niimoodi harjutada.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga nüüd on üks limka.
Õpetaja: Mängime korra lihtsalt neid stsenaariumeid läbi, onju et ma tulen panen siia ühe kommentaari rea
Õpetaja: ja mängime, et City Id väärtus on kaks ja staatus on string.
Õpetaja: Aa Kui oleks. Siukseid sisendeid, siis kuidas tema nüüd hakkaks käituma. On siin ee selliselt Niimoodi, alla
Õpetaja: et vaatame, kui City Id on kaks ja staatusena.
Õpetaja: Kas siin on City Kaks ja status on Aa, järelikult see veel lause rehkenduks truu jääks sõelale
Õpetaja: järgmisega samamoodi jääksellale siin.
Õpetaja: Kas jääks sellele?
Õpetaja: Ei, Sellepärast et City Id ei ole Kaks selle rea puhul. Järelikult selle truuks. Ta ei rehkendu and i poolt Isegi ei vaadata enam teist poolt
Õpetaja: minnakse järgmisele reale, Millised read Jääksid siin säärale.
Õpetaja: Esimene Teine Kui siin oleks kolm, siis jääksid kolmas ja neljas.
Õpetaja: Aga mäletate, Meie teenus on tahetud teha. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: meie teenus on, Ee, tehtud. Ee, selliselt
Õpetaja: leiab, siis tagastab pangaautomaatide asukoha Infot Kui City. Id on null, siis tagastatakse kõik asukohad.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga kui praegult tuleks siia. City Id oleks null sisse.
Õpetaja: Kas see jääks sellele?
Õpetaja: Kas see ei jääks sellele? Kas teist ükski tee järgi saaks sellele jääda, Kui me teame, et kõikid algavad väärtusest. Üks
Õpetaja: ei jää.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd see on minu enda välja mõeldud. Ma ei tea, kas keegi kuskil Päriselt Production is kasutab mingit niukest lähenemist. Vaadake, mure on see, et seda probleemi saaks. Mitut pidi lahendada.
Õpetaja: Me saaksime teha ühe meetodi ka Näiteks Find All Locations.
Õpetaja: Ei, mitte Find all saaks teha niukse meetodi ka juurde. Näiteks ma teen korra juurde. See on vaatamise koht. Otsin kollektsiooni otsin ainult staatuse järgi.
Õpetaja: Otsin staatuse järgi ordering ja teeksin samamoodi järgi. Siis
Õpetaja: Ee, selle lihtsalt name i järgi, et mul on kaks meetodit.
Õpetaja: Ee, Find Location Spy Find Location Spy.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on ainult staatus. Ja nüüd saaks teha niimoodi. See on vaatamise koht Services. Ma saaksin teha niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et mul on kaks eraldi meetodit on vastatajale.
Õpetaja: Üks on nagu, et otsib ainult staatuse järgi. Teine otsib City Id ja Staatuse järgi. Kuidas ma saaksin praegult näiteks selle City Id lahendada, ära et nagu, et, ee. Kui Ikkagi tuleb väärtus null siia sisse, et Vali kõik
Õpetaja: linnad.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma võiksin siis minu? Ma võiksin siia teha.
Õpetaja: See on If, on ju? Ärge nüüd midagi kaasa tehke. If City, Id.
Õpetaja: Ei, City. Adi tuleb igal juhul sisse. Equals, Equals. Mm, ee. Ei saaks ka olla
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et. Kas me hakkame nüüd vaatama Objekti
Õpetaja: See on, see on. See on Jaova klassi versioon. Täisharust
Õpetaja: siin saaks panna, et Kas City Id võrdub liikves ja nüüd see saab mingi väärtuse panna. Ma ütlen, et kui City Id on null,
Õpetaja: mis ma siis tahaks teha?
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ma kirjutaks siis siia Praegult
Õpetaja: Location Repositor I viitame sellele objektile.
Õpetaja: Kutsume välja meetodi Findpy Status või find? No see ülemine on ju No natukene Ma tiimi tiimiks seda seda meetodit
Õpetaja: Ee, seda meetodit ma tingiks, et see oleks Find.
Õpetaja: See jääks ikka samaks
Õpetaja: nii Kui mina. Nüüd, Ee, tulen siia nulliga, siis ma tahaksin otsida. Seda ma korra kustutan ära. Ma muutsin nime, onju? Et kui City Id on null, siis ma tahaksin kutsuda välja Find Location Spy,
Õpetaja: Vaata, aa, mis asi see siin? On? Kuidas mul saab olla kaks samanimelist meetodit
Õpetaja: tuleb kõigile. Teine intriga.
Õpetaja: Üks on string ja teine on. Ja String, on aeg vaadata ära üks õppematerjal, mis tegelikult on teil ka materjalides juba olnud?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma tulen praegu niimoodi siit kiiremini otsin, Ma tahan
Õpetaja: ee signatuur.
Õpetaja: Palju aega kulutame jälle, aga. Okei, Method, Signature and overloading.
Õpetaja: Ee, selline materjal uuesti üle. Vaadata Aga siin see video. Kas see video tuleb kellegile tuttav ette juba pildi järgi?
Õpetaja: Kuidas on jaava Jaavas on? Jaavas on toetatud Ee, selline asi, et,
Õpetaja: ee, kui Meil on mitu erinevat meetodit. Me tahame sama nimega hoida
Õpetaja: seda mängu Ma teate, klotsidega mäng.
Õpetaja: Ta on Niukene kuubik Vaata ja siis mingi Mingid kujundid, mida sealt siia kasti lükata. Aga nad sobivad ainult konkreetsesse auku.
Õpetaja: Minu õppevideo oli ka niimoodi selle mute i peale panna,
Õpetaja: ma Ära saan maha panna siit.
Õpetaja: Ee, minu ee. Lahendus oli ka tehtud niimoodi, et, ee. Oletame. Et meil on mitu meetodit. Paneme korra pausile. On siin Greeting. Greeting. Greeting.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga siin on erinevad signatuurid. Ma ütlen, et siin ta räägib, et kui meil on erinimelised meetodid ja Me kutsu kutsume kuskile seda meetodit välja ja on väga lihtne. See meetod käivitatakse vastavalt sellele meetodi nimele.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on nagu selline olukord Kas ta pausile panna?
Õpetaja: Ee, kus meil on ühte sama meetodi nime? Mitu korda ja jaava seda võimaldab Java Script seda ei võimalda
Õpetaja: sellisel kujul. Sul on küsimus, et vaata, et kuidas ma saan aru. Vaata, kuidas Good peab aru saama, et milline nendest meetoditest niiöelda käivitatakse,
Õpetaja: vaadake Kui need meetodid on defineeritud. Aga nende sisend? Tüübid, tüübid, Mitte need nimed. See, mis on need nimed, on ülisavi tüübid, on erinevad,
Õpetaja: siis Kui sa käivitad mingisugust meetodit ja viskad mingid objektid sisse, siis ta objekti tüüpide järgi teabki, milline on õige õige niiöelda ee, õige signatuuriga, Milline on see, mida ma tahan käivitada?
Õpetaja: No see on Niukene illustreeriv video ka, et meil on kriiting, mis võtab stringi, mis Võtab stringi Ja inti kriiting, mis võtab stringi. Stringi, mis võtab Book ootor objekti sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui me praegu üritame käivitada meetodit, kus sisendiks on selline kuubik? Grete String.
Õpetaja: Siis kuhu? Ta sobib? Kõik asjad ära kasutama. Ja järjekord Mängib ka rolli,
Õpetaja: On ju? Siis ta sobib? Ainult siia, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kuhu Ta sobib? Kuhu ta sobib? Kuhu ta sobib? Kuhu ta? Sobib?
Õpetaja: Nii, siin on väike paus. Ja kuhu ta sobib?
Õpetaja: Ikka siia.
Õpetaja: Need Neli on siin. Representated ei sobi siia. Ei sobi tänna. No ma lähen. No okei, vaatame korra. Paneme see play lihtsalt korra
Õpetaja: Play Blai Play nupp on kogu aeg kadunud. Ei, et siia sobib.
Õpetaja: Sobib siia ka. Aga mis värk on siis, sellega et ta ei sobi, nagu On ju
Õpetaja: järgmine Asi Sobib, Kuhu ta sobib, Sobib, sobib, sobib.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan. Et ta toob selle stringi ka. Põmm nüüd. Siin on veel Selline asi tähtis. Vaata ka, et kui meil on String ja String siis välja kutsudes. Üks on mõeldud First Name, teine on last name
Õpetaja: Kati karu, et Point on see, et väljakutsumisel Sa võid need kuubikud sassi ajada,
Õpetaja: aga mõte on sama. Vaata, String ja String senikaua kuni Meetod on võimalik identifitseerida
Õpetaja: signatuuri ja meetodi nime kujul. Siis on kõik okei.
Õpetaja: No ma tõin siin pigem nüüd ruttu ühe koodi. Näite, onju, et mina tahan teha ruttu siia alla ühe meetodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, public ka. Void Ee, do something.
Õpetaja: Panen siia, et üks meetod on string midagi oma integare Midagi talle ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Pole veel välja kutsutud. Vaata, see on Mingi mõttetu staff. Siin on ka mul siin mingi po pooleli jäi. Vaadake praegult. Ee, selle meetodiga ei ole mingit probleemi,
Õpetaja: kui ma ka teen nüüd sellest ee samast asjast variatsiooni, teen tubli Catiga,
Õpetaja: kui Mina panen niimoodi, et on esimene.
Õpetaja: String on teine.
Õpetaja: Mis So something? Sama nimi tal endiselt Tegelikult ei ole mingit probleemi meetodiga,
Õpetaja: kui aga Ma panen siia näiteks niimoodi, et sellepärast, et kui ma nüüd üritan välja kutsuda siin Private meetodeid et käivita mehed saavad
Õpetaja: something,
Õpetaja: siis tal on Kaks varianti Interjar String. String Interchaire. Nüüd, kui mina kirjutan siia String ja siia panen mingi numbri. Kumma meetodi ta käivitab? No näeme. Läks juba siniseks,
Õpetaja: sest see, mis sobis. Vaata tüübi järgi. Ta teab
Õpetaja: nimelt, kui panin täpselt samad nimed ka midagi. Vot see ongi probleem. Vaata midagi, üks,
Õpetaja: midagi, kaks. Siin oli nagu praegult. Oli nagu päriselt viga, Onju Erinimega pead olema ju parameetrid Nii
Õpetaja: Ee, et kumb nendest käivitatakse, kui aga mina Nüüd tahaksin teha siia juurde ühe meetodi veel.
Õpetaja: See on tublid. Käid ja see jääb täpselt sama interjet. Näen, nime Võin ära muuta.
Õpetaja: Nimed ei mängi rolli. See on savi. Praegu oleks see, et kui mina nüüd üritaks käivitada
Õpetaja: ringi, Ma panen numbri. Oota, Kui Ta praegu teab Stringi jab ära, nagu et tuleb see käivitada. Aga kui ma paneksin siia üks ja siia panen stringi üks,
Õpetaja: siis Tal on küsimus nagu, et. Aga mul on kaks meetodit, mis on sama nimega ja sama signatuuriga, et noh, kumma ma siis käivitama pean,
Õpetaja: Ta Ei teagi.
Õpetaja: Polegi võimalik, Aga kui nüüd tulla vaatame, siis ta ütleb ka Something Intager String Isolwity Defind
Õpetaja: skoobis juba on olemas sama asja. Vaata, ta ütleb, et see on olemas juba.
Õpetaja: Sa pead midagi. Kui ma paneksin siia juurde. Veel Interjan. Näiteks põmm,
Õpetaja: mida iganes, jälle Enam ei ole probleemi. Kumb, mis käivitub? Ta teab signatuur. On see tüüpide tüüpide mõttes? Vaata, parameetrite tüübid on ka osa signatuurist.
Õpetaja: Miks ma sellest rääkisin, on see, et meil ongi praegu täpselt see olukord. Ee, kui me tuleme siia tagasi,
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu siin olin, kustutan selle jama ära,
Õpetaja: et kui mina hakkan nüüd käivitama, et kui City Id, ärge kaasa tehke, onju midagi käivitama. Mul on kaks samanimelist meetodit
Õpetaja: no antud juhul mind tegelikult huvitab, siis kumb, kui on Null.
Õpetaja: City Id on null. Tahan kõik linnad otsida.
Õpetaja: Ei, sest alumine just eeldab seda, et Ma annan City Id väärtuse. Aga ma ju ei taha nüüd anda seda City väärtust. Mis on null?
Õpetaja: Ta ju ei leia mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: ju tuleb ju täpselt siia. Tagasi. Siia tabelisse. Ee, kus see Location tabel on? Siin,
Õpetaja: Kas on null? Ei, Ole, ei ole, ei ole, ei ole. Kui me otsime ainult staatuse järgi anname A
Õpetaja: Leian, leian, leian, leian saate mõttest, aru On ju,
Õpetaja: et If iga oleks see võimalik teha.
Õpetaja: Aa, sisse tuleks If Else, et ee. Kui
Õpetaja: City Id on null, siis käivita Find Location Spy ja ma annan siia kaasa Näiteks staatuse Aa
Õpetaja: teistel juhtudel. Käivita Location Repository Find Location, Buy City. Noh, nüüd on mingi päris väärtus City D koma
Õpetaja: ja staatuseks annan Näiteks A.
Õpetaja: Üks variant oleks seda niimoodi teha. Teil on kaks eraldi meetodit, mis andib seda olukorda. Aga
Õpetaja: sellega, kui kaugele te purjetate, siin hakkab tekkima see, et astmeliselt lähevad See If ide jada läheb keerulisemaks.
Õpetaja: Aga mis siis, kui mul on veel mingi filter,
Õpetaja: kus ka on Sama põhimõte, et kui on null, võta kõik.
Õpetaja: Kui ei ole. Näiteks Location Id on null. Ma kujutage ette või staatus, või mida iganes, Vaata, on meil mingid filtrid,
Õpetaja: Et ta on üks või teine. Vaata aga nulliga üldse ja kõik. Siis see tähendab seda, et meil tekib niimoodi, et kui üks on null, aga teine ei ole. See on üks olukord
Õpetaja: Kahest, et üks on null, teine ei ole null ühte Ära filtreeri teist Filtreeri, Aga sa pead vastupidi ka, et see esimene on Hoopis ei ole null, aga teine pool on null. Sul tekib Juba kahega tekib su laused kokku minimaalselt kolm. Ja kui on mõlemad nullid, on veel kolmas variant. Võibolla muidugi ka,
Õpetaja: et mida rohkem tuleb Vaata sinna juurde. Neid potentsiaalseid par. Nagu olukordi. Filtreeri Ära filtreeri, Kui me tahame seda niimoodi programmiliselt lahendada, kui sul on näiteks siin kaks Kolm asja siis juba on potentsiaalsed. If ide lause. Kus sul on mingi kaheksa ifi ühes või teisel diesel. Sellepärast, et sul on kolm
Õpetaja: Kolm sisendit, mille puhul on vaja midagi vaadata sellega, nagu selles mõttes kaugele ei purjeta. Mina mõtlesin välja palju lollikindlama süsteemi.
Õpetaja: Ma olen korra tegelikult seda juba teinud. Ee, teen ühe korra veel. Siis selle aja. Ee, võtan korra lahti. Query. Console
Õpetaja: Võtan. Selle sama lause select From Location Tabelist on ju
Õpetaja: Mu skeema peab ära panema. Pank Ee location.
Õpetaja: Need on kõik Ee. Panen nad ta siia. In Ineditor ideeks. Need on kõikvõimalikud. Variandid on nii,
Õpetaja: kui mina Teen selle alla lause. Select From Pank Location
Õpetaja: Wear ja panen lihtsalt tingimused. True
Õpetaja: valitakse kõik read
Õpetaja: Kui mina panen. Siia. Kas null? Et Where? Kus null on? Null. Ma ei viita ühelegi veerule. Ma lihtsalt ütlen otse mulle kõik Read Location tabelist. Kus null on null, Aga ma ei viita nagu millelegi.
Õpetaja: Öelge veerule, Ma ei viita.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt konstruktsioon. Vaata, noh, võin, samamoodi teha. Kas kas Ee Mati on
Õpetaja: mati? Mis Mati on? Mati?
Õpetaja: Tulevad. Kõik read tulevad. Kui minu konstruktsioon oleks selline, et kas null on null, siis tuleks kõik. Read nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma paneksin siia, and iga juurde. And City Id võrdub.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, mitte änd, vaid hoopis Voor
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame praegu seda lauset, et, ee, me mõtleme.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui meil on selline konstruktsioon, et vaata, kus null on, Null
Õpetaja: või City Id on null, Siis kas see jääb truuks või
Õpetaja: Miks truuks? No võib öelda. Vaata, kas City Id on null. No vaatan, Ei, ole ju null.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see on hoor, onju? Kui üks pooltest on tõene, siis on tõene, on ju edasi. Tegelikult isegi siin ei Ole vaja vaadata, et kui tuleb siia sellele reale, vaatab, kas null on null. Ja kas null on null? Ja kas null on null? Ja kas null on null?
Õpetaja: Jah, on ju, Aga kui mul see sisend näiteks oleks hoopis see, et City mis tuleb sisse, on kaks,
Õpetaja: oleks selline konstruktsioon. Tuleme selle peale. Kas null on kaks?
Õpetaja: Ah? False ei ole, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga siis vaatame edasi. Aga kas City Id on? Kaks on.
Õpetaja: Järgmise Rea puhul oleks ka. On.
Õpetaja: Kas ee null? Ee, Vabandust, Kas null on kaks? Ei ole, Kas City Id on Kaks
Õpetaja: ei ole, ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui me vaataksime niukest konstruktsiooni, et kas sisend on null
Õpetaja: või City Id on siis mis iganes See sisend on siis selline konstruktsioon töötakski.
Õpetaja: See on minu geniaalsus, mis ma välja mõtlesin. Ja nüüd, kui meil oleks siin mitmeid asju, mida filtreerida. Ja kui me soovime niimoodi, et mitte filtreerimine on null, siis igale poole. Kui me teeme samasuguse konstruktsiooni, et kas see sisend on null, siis see, nagu töötabki. Ta võtab kõik read, aga ta vaatab ka teisi tingimusi. Staatus on ka. Ju,
Õpetaja: on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie tahamegi teha. Täpi pealt seda sama asja. Vaata, see ongi meil sisend, Sisend?
Õpetaja: See on siin samamoodi sisend.
Õpetaja: Ja näiteks Nüüd need ma korra võtaksin sulgudega kokku, et silmadel on lihtsam vaadata.
Õpetaja: Sisend, sisend. Mis on nagu meid. Vabandust, City. Sisend City Id sisend Saate mõttest ära.
Õpetaja: See tuleb meil sisse, et meie vaatame nagu neid asju.
Õpetaja: Ja siis me vaatame ühtlasi veel. And iga and status pöördub. Siin oleks staatus, sisend,
Õpetaja: saate aru. No status, sisend. Me juba teame, et on.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin Ma saan niimoodi panna, A on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd mängime, Vaata, et kui City It Sisend on kaks.
Õpetaja: Proovime läbi City Id Sis on kaks.
Õpetaja: Staatus on A.
Õpetaja: Tuleb sikupilliprisma Kui ma mängin, et sisend on null
Õpetaja: null, siis tegelikult vaadatakse. Kõik read lähevad seda. City Id ei vaadata sellepärast, et see saab lihtsalt true.
Õpetaja: Siis on ta null, See diadeid Isegi ei huvita.
Õpetaja: Tulid kõik.
Õpetaja: Noh, Number of Htms Ga saab näiteks ka mängida. Näiteks juurde, vaata onju ja panna näiteks and ee, number of Htms.
Õpetaja: Number Adens on sisend.
Õpetaja: Näiteks mängin, et on mingi. On ju? Tahan siin samamoodi teha. Vaata, et kui kasutaja valib, et otsi mulle kõik need kohad, kus on kaks
Õpetaja: automaati.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd ta leidis need. Ee, Kõik linnad, onju
Õpetaja: Kliendid, kõik linnad. Aga ta filtreerib praegult et Number of I järgi,
Õpetaja: Kui tahaks siin ka, et et kuidagi saad valida. Või tahan lihtsalt seda, et kõike on võimalik valida. Vaata, et Frontist tuleb null. Ma saaksin siia teha täpi pealt samasuguse konstruktsiooni, et panen selle sulgude vahele ja ütlen, et ee,
Õpetaja: vaata
Õpetaja: fooriga kahte poolt ja siis vaatad samamoodi ka, et kas null on Null
Õpetaja: nüüd on nagu et. Kas null on null?
Õpetaja: Jah, jäävad kõik sõelale, et See filter ei kehti. Aga niipea, kui on päris sisend. Vaat kaks, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ma saan väga odavalt tegelikult siin selle lähenemisega Ee, teha niimoodi, et ma saan. Kas filtree, kui on kui null? Ei, sest et null on. Vaata, mida kuskil niikuinii ei saa olla. Vaata Id na, Kui me räägime Id Dest Idest, onju?
Õpetaja: Igasugused grupeerimise filtri filtreerimised, mis lähevad. Sul ongi näiteks see, et ee soovin. Näiteks nagu elektroonika, on Esimene filter.
Õpetaja: See on üks kategooria. Tal on oma Id
Õpetaja: elektroonika. Ee, soovin. Ee. Mingi ee. Audio
Õpetaja: audio video. Need on jälle võibolla potentsiaalsed Mingid kategooriad filtreerimine. Samamoodi ma saan teha, et kui kasutaja midagi ei vali, vaata siis. Filter on null
Õpetaja: ja läheme sügavamale sügavamale sügavale ja See asi töötab Jumala lolli. Kindlalt
Õpetaja: Nagu üli lollikindlalt, Et sa oled üli tšillid. Vahet pole, kuidas sa kombineerid neid filtreid, Vaata, et kas Kasutaja valib midagi või vali. Midagi. On üli lihtne. Teed lihtsalt seda võrdust selle nulliga ja teed sellise konstruktsiooni. Vaata, et, noh, see rehkendub Lihtsalt truuks. Vaata seda, seda veermine. Ei, vaata.
Õpetaja: Sa vaatad seda. Veergu. Ei, vaata, vaata nii, vaata, vaatan ja vaata, Vaatan ja vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, ma ei mäletagi, kuidas ma selle peale tulin. See ei olnud mingi Chat I abiga. Mida iganes. Vaata vaid. Ma lihtsalt ise mõtlesin Oile. Kuidas saaks? Sest et mul oli üks. Kuidas ma selle läbi mängisin, oligi, see et keegi tegi nagu ee, niukest süsteemi, kus oli Päris palju niiöelda kombineeritud filtreerimist.
Õpetaja: Ja me üritasime If idega teha. Siis vaatasime Kurat, sa lähed nastiks kätte. Vaata, on ju No siis? Oli Variant muidugi sealt ära peita. Ee, aga nagu ma mõtlen, saab ka If Lauset teha, On, kui sa tahad
Õpetaja: aga tuli nagu nii, sest Sa pidid kogu aeg vaatama mitut poolt,
Õpetaja: et kui see esimene null ja viimane on null, siis niimoodi,
Õpetaja: kui on esimesed kaks null, siis on niimoodi, kui on tagumised kaks null. Kui kõik on null, kui ükski pole null, If, if, if, if, if,
Õpetaja: põmm, Jamius, Üks siia Ja üks rida ja mure murtud. Jah,
Õpetaja: Keegi tuleb pärast sind, et. Kas sa meetodi nimes üritasid seda tegeldada või? Jah, tegelikult oleks võim oleks vaja. Vaata teha mingi hägusus siia sisse. Ma mõtlen, et praegu ongi, see, et et me. Kui me tuleme praegu jadapidi, Vaata, sellest Ee, kui me tuleme
Õpetaja: kui me tuleme. Niiöelda. Ee, kui me tuleme sealt. Kontroller klassist. Alati see loeme koodi. Siis Me näeme ära, et Seal on see tingimus sees.
Õpetaja: Aga vaadake, see meetod on eraldiseisev meetod, mis ei tea välisest elust ööd ega mütsi. See meetod ei tohi olla kuidagi nagu selles mõttes. Nagu Connected. Ta ei olegi Connected meetod. Kutsu, kus tahes
Õpetaja: taaskasutada seda sama meetodit, mis meie nüüd praegu loome, on ju kust tahes. Ja seal ongi see mõte, mida praegu Jaanus juba praegu tõi Sisse vaata, on see, et. Et. Aga kas sa Kui sa sisse. See on loogika ära peidetud. Kas sa kuidagi peegeldad seda selles meetodi nimes? Jah, seda peaks tegema.
Õpetaja: Ma ise pakuks, et Paneme mingi sõna mingi juurde ja mängime, et. Ee. Meil on Niukene arhitektuur. Mida me oleme. Oma meeskonnaga tutvustanud, et
Õpetaja: et kui te tahate mingit filtreerimist teha, Siis kasutage sellist lähenemist. On ju? Ja konventsioon ja tava on siis kasutada mingeid märksõna juures,
Õpetaja: Aga see oleks niikuinii, vaata et kui sa loe, kui sa olekski lihtsalt poodi, vaata. Ja ma isegi sellest reeglist midagi ei Tee Siin on vaja panna mingisugune sõna juurde. Vaata, mis nagu tõmbab tähelepanu. Vaata, et vaata. Meetod on. Mäletan, ma olen rääkinud meetod Meetodi nimi ei tohi valetada.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tohi rääkida mingisugusest tegevusest. Ee, mida ta ütleb, et teen mingisugust X asja ka. Aga tegelikult meetod ei tee meetod nagu reklaamib rohkem välja. Noh, Toon näite reklaami välja.
Õpetaja: Kunagi käisime sõbravennaga Mingi üheksakümnendatel autoturge. Mäletate? Autoturgud? Küll oli lahe koht, kus käia kolamas ja vaadata unistamas seal mingi Poisikestena leidsid mingi penni, Ron? Oi, ma ema peale pahane, et ei tahtnud mulle kuusteist tuhat krooni anda. Kuidagi
Õpetaja: nägin niukest Penny, mis oli Valge, ülimadal, tuunitud nagu Mingid spoila ringid Värgid, et teist kahe kahene mootor oli juurde pandud selgelt auto, mis nagu karjus probleemidest, Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: Ja tahtsin Ema, laena palun mulle osamaksetega. Kuidagi ma tahan seda autot osta. Ma ütlesin, Kuule, vaata seda autot. Nagu ma ütlesin, pilt asju.
Õpetaja: Kindel ait. Ei, anna ta mul seda raha nii pahane olin. Jumal tänatud,
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja siis ükskord käisime sõbravennaga. Käisime nagu autoturul. Vaata, noh, Vanem mentor, nagu ikka, päriselt otsis autod.
Õpetaja: Autol oli suuresti juurde kirjutatud. Siis sellel paberil, et kõik, mis uhked asjad nagu on, Vaata, on ju. Ja siis seal oli loomulikult Abs. Pidurid.
Õpetaja: Aa, vend. Oli tal piisavalt nagu tehni. Tehniliselt taiplik, et oskas asju vaadata. Vaatas sinna autosse sisse ja siis ütles, et. Kuule, sorry, aga
Õpetaja: siin ei ole ju neid Abs pidureid. Ja. Siis see tüüp, kes nagu seda üritas seal müüa, aga, noh, see on rohkem nagu reklaamiks või nii,
Õpetaja: et meetodi nimega on nüüd samamoodi nagu, et nagu see, et nagu, et lihtsalt nagu Midagi reklaamida, mida tegelikult ei tehta, On nagu Nato laud. Noh, täna nagu ma ütleks, mingi tarbijakaitse ja mingid asjad, Vaata, et noh, Kuidas Te saate
Õpetaja: ee petta tähendab, mis tarbijakaitses? See on nagu potentsiaalselt nagu kriminaalne värk. Isegi võibolla onju
Õpetaja: ja meetodi nimega on samamoodi, et Ta ei tohi valetada kahtepidi. Ta ei tohi meile reklaamida abs pidureid, mida pole, on ju Aga Teistpidi on samamoodi ka see et ei ole Ka ilus, Vaata, et, ee, ta ei räägi. Vaata, mis seal sees toimub. Ta jätab midagi teadmata, Aga nüüd see kolmas variant ongi siin keskel. See, et vahel ongi, siis vaja jätta asjad häguseks. Oleme teinud seda handel
Õpetaja: mingi location response. Ja mida iganes ta ei ütle Täpselt mis ta teeb.
Õpetaja: Ta Ütleb, et Kind A, mida ta teeb, aga ta päris täpselt ei ütle, et siin selles mõttes ee urmas Nagu väga elutargalt. Juba nagu urmas jälle vä.
Õpetaja: Ainsouri. Peeter.
Õpetaja: Ah jaanus. Jaanus.
Õpetaja: Jah, tead, mul savi Minu jaoks. Oled surmas nüüd edaspidi mul on endal lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, no näed, tuleb teistel ka Seda
Õpetaja: ehk. Siis ee. Teeme nüüd selle asja ära, et me võtame ikkagi selle esimese variandi.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd kõik see, mida me siin selles konsoolis harjutasime ja mõtlesime, et sisendit tuleb lihtsalt vaadata, et kui see on null, et Me paneme, võtame selle ülemise meetodi,
Õpetaja: kaasa arvatud urmas.
Õpetaja: Ja see koht siin, kus Me, vaatame City Id, D, siis me ei vaata ainult seda City Id D, Vaid me vaatame seda sisendit ennast
Õpetaja: ja ütleme Ori Abil kaks poolt, et kui City Id see on koolon,
Õpetaja: kui City Id, siis ta nüüd ei taha viidata talle.
Õpetaja: Ma pean vastupidi panema kõigepealt nulli, kui null
Õpetaja: võrdub City Id ga, sest tal lihtsalt see ei meeldinud Või tal tegelt. Miks Mulle meeldiks niipidi mõelda? Ikkagi ma panen selle kooloni siia kuidagi ära. Colon City
Õpetaja: Id võrdub null, Ma olen Ikea. Mine nüüd. Vot nii.
Õpetaja: Kui sisend on null või tabelis City Id on City Id väärtusega,
Õpetaja: siis ta rehkendub truuks, on Nii, Ja and iga vaadatakse staatust niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on siis ee see, mida Jaanus
Õpetaja: ütles et kas kuidagi meetodi nimi ka seda peegeldab?
Õpetaja: Võibolla paneks midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: et see. Ei, Sa ei ütle nagu päris täpselt ära, nagu mis siin toimub.
Õpetaja: Aga ta midagi ütleb, et kui Klassikaliselt kuskil mujal ei näe. Ja mingi arendaja järsku näeb, siis ta ei võiks nagu mingi pirn põlema minna, et
Õpetaja: siin on midagi, mida Nagu hägusalt öeldakse, aga ei ole otse nagu kirjas.
Õpetaja: Ja kui nüüd minna sinna Locations Servicesse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me kavatsemegi Location repositoriga kutsuda välja
Õpetaja: Fine Filtered Locations. Buy, Vaata, seda näekski.
Õpetaja: Kas me näeme seda, mis seal koeri taga on? Praegult siin ei näe.
Õpetaja: Kui seda sõna poleks, siis Ee, on Find Location Spy City Id.
Õpetaja: Ja nii edasi, et üldse ei teaks, et seal midagi on. Veel.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt selle järgi mõtleks kohe, et Jah, otsid City staatuse järgi. Väga tore.
Õpetaja: Tema ütlebki, et see City Id. No see. Tuleb meile ju siia meetodisse sisse internetist, kuni Võib öelda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on ee, küsimus, et. Ee. Siis mis siis siia peab minema? Staatus, mis peaks, minema siia.
Õpetaja: Jah, eesmärk on loomulikult et See peaks haavama. Jumal, kui keegi hakkaks ütlema lihtsalt praegult siin, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ma ei, tea. Vaata, nüüd ei ole enam isegi mingit Dto Objekti vaid on, lihtsalt seda ei saa kasutada, on ju? Midagi muud pole. See on see, mis nagu algajatel tõmbab. Juhtme kinni, et me Saame koodi ise ka väärtuse kirjutada, aga lihtsalt see. Võibolla ei kõneta kedagi.
Õpetaja: See võib olla ei kõneta kedagi, aga kui me viitame Enumile nimega Staatus,
Õpetaja: mille me ise siia tegime. Status Ebcs pank ja vaatame, et temal
Õpetaja: on olemas Niukene staatus Nagu Active ja tema sisu on naa.
Õpetaja: Aga me peame seda kuidagi kätte ka saama.
Õpetaja: Get Code annabki meile selle väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui lugeda seda asja, et see on täiesti mõttetu.
Õpetaja: Selle saame eest ära kaotada. Ja importida konkreetset status active Enumi sisse.
Õpetaja: Kustutame selle ära.
Õpetaja: Punane virnal. Enter näeb, et niuksed staatused on ka mujal. Täiesti uskumatu.
Õpetaja: Impordime selle sisse.
Õpetaja: Ongi olemas. Kui nüüd praegu keegi tuleks, loeks seda. No kui ta tuleb sellest kontrollerist, siis ta vast märkab seda. Ja see võiks talle panna nagu mingisuguse mõtte.
Õpetaja: Aga kui isegi ta lihtsalt. Keegi satuks siia ja näeks rida Find Locations
Õpetaja: Find Location Repositori. Misasja City Id läheb kaasa. Status Act. I Läheb kaasa, et vot mis siis toimub siin? Nagu.
Õpetaja: No siis ta tuleb vaatab siit ja siis ta näeb,
Õpetaja: et Ee hakkab vaatama. Et mis siin on, siis otsi Locations tabelist, kus City Id, et kus kui City Id on null või City. Id on tabelis selle väärtusega olemas. Ma võibolla isegi Swapiksin neid ringi. Ma isegi ei tea praegult
Õpetaja: Ee, Need kaks omavahel. Justkui kui null on, ei teinud seda. Ma ikka mõtleks niipidi. Ee, lugedes pusides küll ta aru saaks. Lõpuks mis siin, Nagu siis toimub.
Õpetaja: Ja pealegi päriselus. Kui meil juba oleks Niukene Approach läbivalt, siis me niikuinii oleks seda dokumentatsioonis kuskil kirjas ka
Õpetaja: ja ütleme Niimoodi, et ühel või teisel viisil
Õpetaja: Ee, kui mitte. No siis tuleb siia. Vaatad, kes selle koodilehe kirjutas. Äkki olen küsinud ema käest või Ai käest. Küsin, et mis siin toimub. Mis see mõte on?
Õpetaja: Panime küllalt kirja jõu. Selle. Kui on null, siis
Õpetaja: No jah, aga vaata, Point on see. Vaata, et see koodilõik oma elust ei tea ööd ega mütsi. Jah, keegi kasutab teda ja me saame seda dressida, vaata, Aga see mõte ongi nagu see, et. Vaata, kui sa kuskil mujal seda kasutad, siis sa tahad ka, kui sa kuskilt välja kutsuma, Kui Ta oleks lihtsalt vaata Locations,
Õpetaja: et keegi näiteks siia sisse vaatama ei tule
Õpetaja: ja kutsub seda meetodit välja eesmärgiga, et ta annab ainult ja Kohe saab siis kõik Location Id. Ta ei tea isegi sellest tingimusest. See Mõte ongi. Lihtsalt eelkõige seda, et keegi potentsiaalselt kunagi tulevikus taaskasutaks seda meetodit. Aga kui sa Filterit ei ole, siis ta võib seda taaskasutada kogemata pugiga.
Õpetaja: Siin on midagi, mida ta ei tea,
Õpetaja: ja selle nimi lihtsalt on tema jaoks kummaline. Siis ta vähemalt tuleb. Vaatab seda asja. Ta võiks nii või naa tulla vaatama. Aga kui see on Suhteliselt standardne värk. Vaata, Find Location. Siis ta lihtsalt. Ei, ta ei tule selle Pealegi,
Õpetaja: ta. Ta hoolib selle välja ja ta väga ei Tule, võibolla keskenduma. Ja siis ongi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No päris elus võib muidugi olla veel üks kiht serviskiht vahel. Kus Ee, üldse oleks muud asjad, Aga ma sellest isegi ei räägi.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Mida paberi tugevalt, et sa mõtled seda, et kui City Id on null,
Õpetaja: noh, sa juba mõtled Ahah, kui see on null seda välja ei vaadatagi, on ju, et filterd
Õpetaja: siis seda ei filtreerime, välja et seda me ei vaatagi, Noh, Ma ütlen kuidagi. Siin võib mõelda veel siin mingi meetodinimi. Võibolla võiks ka midagi muud olla, onju Ma pole Chatiga kunagi arutanud. Kui päris aus olla. Ma pole varasemate kursustega isegi seda sõna pannud. Kuigi ma olen alati sellest rääkinud, et siin peaks olema, aga me ka enda ei ole viitsinud midagi mõelda.
Õpetaja: Täna Ma lihtsalt mõtlesin, et mis see sõna võiks Siis olla? Vaata, et
Õpetaja: et see võiks midagi muud ka olla. Okei? Ee, Fine Filtered locations.
Õpetaja: Mida see meetod tagastab Location Ite listi. Vot nii Lähme tagasi sinna, kohta
Õpetaja: kus on see meetod välja kutsutud.
Õpetaja: Mis teda võiks teha järgmise sammuna
Õpetaja: muuta, ikka, onju? Vähemalt keegi teine vastas vahelduseks ka. Kus oli Angrete?
Õpetaja: Tubli,
Õpetaja: et Ee, Noh, ma Juba muidugi üldse vihjeid, on ju? Aga see ongi täpselt see, kuidas te progedest mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Kutsun välja meetode, mis midagi annab.
Õpetaja: Panen ta siis muutujasse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta pakub lihtsalt selle Find I järgi, et me tahaks pigem muud muutuja nime
Õpetaja: ta võtab. Praegu lihtsalt meetodi nime järgi arvab, et me otsime, et see on mingi objekt. Filter ei ole. Mis on meie objekt?
Õpetaja: See muuta nimi. Oleks parim
Õpetaja: Muidugi Keep it a Simple As Possible.
Õpetaja: Alati võimalikult täpselt. Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee. Niiöelda seda tüüpi kirjeldab. Aga see lihtsalt variant. See ei ta Pakub. Ka, seal. Aga vaadake, Valikute järjekorras. Ta pakkus seda vähemalt lõpu poole rohkem. No mul kadus juba ära. Ma Panen lihtsalt selle
Õpetaja: Okei? Ee, Locationsete listi. Saime kätte.
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd edasi?
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: See on Entiti. Jumal teab siin mingit palju asju või midagi. Võibolla puudub meil. Niikuinii on vaja, Meil on. See on normaalne. See ongi kõik. Asjad, andmed liiguvad. Tta. Me objekte ei tohi tagastada. Süsteemist välja ei tohi,
Õpetaja: siis on vaja teha, Siis on vaja mõelda, et kas meil juba on Niukene objekt olemas? Location Aid, See on ka asi, vaata. Noh, nüüd meil hakkab süsteem arenema.
Õpetaja: Kas meil äkki on mingi klass olemas?
Õpetaja: Mis on sihukese struktuuriga?
Õpetaja: No kohe kindlasti Ei ole. Pole nagu teinud midagi niukest vaja luua midagi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nagu see, et ee, Kutžha tõtab appi, Teeks seda Kutshaga.
Õpetaja: Kui me teame, et need andmed pärinevad location i pealt,
Õpetaja: siis Me võiksime võtta kainda selle. Noh, lähme sinna Klassi
Õpetaja: kontrolli või kontroll Bga, et võtame siis selle maksimum andmed praegu,
Õpetaja: mis meil seal on, Listi kujul.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis siin on, on põhimõtteliselt olemas,
Õpetaja: et siis võiks teha parema klõpsu Tema peal hakkame tegema uut. Mida Me just rääkisime, Tt o klassi
Õpetaja: by the way kui. Tto Entity On juba olemas kui. Tuleb selline olukord
Õpetaja: siis, on ka võimalik lihtsalt kui sul on kaks poolt olemas, et kutsel on veel variante. Mis siit võiks huvi pakkuda? Ühel või teisel hetkel,
Õpetaja: kui meil on olemas Identity ja Tto,
Õpetaja: Jah, et varem või hiljem juhtub ka see, kus tegelikult need klassid on juba olemas. Entity D on ammu olemas. Teeme mingi Tto. Kasutame Tto D Ühes kohas. Tto D. Teises kohas. Sama Dtos. Sama struktuuriga info.
Õpetaja: Aga siis on võibolla mingit mäperit vaja. Vaata, no idee, muidugi. See mapper võiks siis ka juba olemas olla, selleks ajaks. Aga see variant, et Interface saab ka teha, siis ta lihtsalt nõuab, et anna mulle Location ja anna mulle mingi Dto klasse. Ma üritan Mapper It teha vaata enam mapinguid. Niikuinii ei tea, lihtsalt ideer kütan et, see on ka olemas. Sealt
Õpetaja: Ee, meeshoime ttod, et hakkame ülevalt tulema. Entiti on meil paigas.
Õpetaja: Ee Pakub nimeks Location Tto.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Aa, ma ei ole veel rääkinud sellest kontseptsioonist aga
Õpetaja: meil hakkab tekkima süsteemides. Suure tõenäosusega võib tekkida selline klass, millega on potentsiaalselt võimalik teha kolme tegevust
Õpetaja: mingi Konkreetse uue objekti lisamine. Mingi uue tabeli andme ridamine,
Õpetaja: selle sama. Need samad andmed, millest me just rääkisime. Vaata, nende muutmine
Õpetaja: ja nende kuvamine, Noh, näiteks see, et kui sul on mingi vorm, kus on mingid väljad, seal saab asju lisada, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd suure tõenäosusega, täpselt selle Sama vormiga, kõiki asju update ida üle kirjutada
Õpetaja: ja saaks ka teha niukse teenuse, mis pärib kõik need andmed, et see sama voor meel Ära täita eesmärgiga, et sa tahad sealt siis teha mingeid muudatusi saate mõttest aru, et meil võib olla potentsiaalselt selline klass, mida tegelikult saaks kasutada pea kolmel eesmärgil
Õpetaja: kolmel eesmärgil, et lisada andmeid, konkreetseid andmeid, location andmeid, näiteks kustut mitte kustutada vaid Ee muuta neid üle kirjutada
Õpetaja: ja ka lihtsalt pärida neid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Vot, ee, kui meil tekib selline klass, vaata siis, ee, et me saame need Me peame nende Tt klassidele mingeid nimesid panema.
Õpetaja: Ja minu mõte on nagu see. Vaata, et see Tto võiks olla niimoodi, et kui me teame, et meil on mingisugune Potentsiaalne Niukene klass. Siis tahaks reserveerida selle variandi Tto just selle jaoks, sellise klassi jaoks.
Õpetaja: Aga kui meil nüüd on vaja mingeid variatsioone teha klassidest. Vaata siis. Me ei taha enam panna Dtv kaks. Või Jumal teab midagi nihukest, onju?
Õpetaja: Päris nii ei taha, on ju, et, ee, Mul on küsimus, lihtsalt see, kui me vaatame praegult seda klassi.
Õpetaja: Kas see potentsiaalselt võiks olla selline klass,
Õpetaja: millega me saame lisada Location It,
Õpetaja: Siin on juba üks väli, mis nagu välistab Selle
Õpetaja: Esiteks, City Name. Meil on seosed Tegelikult mitte imedega, vaid
Õpetaja: Id Dega, aga veel rohkem On see Location Id?
Õpetaja: Näiteks postsõnumis? Nagu, et, ee, et võta vormilt kõik andmed kokku. Ee, sisestame süsteemi uue Location I.
Õpetaja: Mida kuradit sa sinna paned, Kui see pole veel isegi tekkinud. Ja see selle sama protsessi käigus tekib.
Õpetaja: Kas sa võiks, öelda, et update? Il võiks seda justkui kasutada. Ja. Aga sa saad ju saata mingi info niiöelda Selle Jason sõnumis. Ja mingi info Urli Sees
Õpetaja: update, ei piisaks, et on Need kõik väljad, mis on seal vormil. Ja kui on Id ka vaja kaasa panna, et mida me uuendama hakkame? Palun väga, pane see Lihtsalt seal. Request parameetris või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, kui ma üritan jõuda, on see. Vaata, et see konkreetne objekt lihtsalt ei sobiks minu ee Visiooniga Ee Tto nimetuseks, Sest me tahame seda kasutada hiljem lisamisel.
Õpetaja: Hästi, võibolla lutsika reegel on see, et ee, kui mingisuguseid andmeid saab, lisada Siis see Tto variant võiks olla reserveeritud sellele, sest suure tõenäosusega saad seda Editis kasutada. Ja võibolla ka andmete puhandamiseks.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole. Praegu See olukord.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et nüüd me peame hakkama mõtlema mingisugust nime. Sellepärast, et klassi nime Location me ei saa jätta see on juba entiti poolt hõivatud.
Õpetaja: Mingi muu nime peame panema.
Õpetaja: Noh, see nüüd hakkab jälle see Creativity pihta.
Õpetaja: Aa, pakkusin kunagi keegi mingi sõna Data Koodis väldiks väldiks. Seda sõna. Mina paneks selle asja nimeks. Näiteks mingi location Info.
Õpetaja: Ee, vältige Ee frontend. I viiteid. Kõik võiks panna ka Näiteks mingi Location table.
Õpetaja: Mingi näiteks. Niimoodi võiks tahta. Mõned tahavad juba kirjutada. Mingeid Selecte asju sisse või asju. See on. See on infosüsteem Hoiame asja äriloogilisena. Mõtleme nagu valdkondadele ja asjadele. Nagu rohkem niimoodi kasuta, et praegu ma näiteks ma mõtlekski, et ma, paneks mingi ma ei tea, Location info.
Õpetaja: Kui näiteks tuleks mingi variatsioon veel, sellest, kus on näiteks rohkem infost. Infot saaks ka hiljem ka. Näiteks. Ma ei tea, Mingi location info või midagi tahaks. Vaata mõttes ta aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina seda objekti praegult ette jaoks ei paneks.
Õpetaja: Paneks hoopis location info kuna, ma üldse soovitan teil tegelikult ka läheneda
Õpetaja: teie projektides. Kui te hakkate teenuseid tegema, tehke Aa, Nagu mõttes neid,
Õpetaja: et kõigepealt tekib ära kõik Teenused. Teil tulevadki seal. Need ttod juba. Vaata, mis te mõtlete. Oo, mis ma saan lisada? Alati võid panna Request näiteks Vaata, et nagu, et lisan andmeid, Aga lihtsalt ongi point. On see et niipea, kui sa tahad mingit vormi eel täita,
Õpetaja: sest suure tõenäosusega sama objekt sobib andmekanditeks ideaalse kandidaadina. Ja siis oleks väga imelik näha kuskil responsis seda nagu, noh, sissetuleku. Hästi,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et kui te seda järjekorda liigute, et te teete ee, kõigepealt ära. Nagu need visamise teenused, siis te juba seal reserveerite selle
Õpetaja: bla, bla, blabla tto ära ja hiljem niikuinii Vaata, kui tahate mingit muud
Õpetaja: selle infokillu nii öelda. Objekti tehas. Te olete sundseisus, midagi muud. Mõtleme välja, kui teete. Et Praegult on see Järjekord me. Me teeme riitegevust ennem kui posti, aga teen. Ma soovitan tegelikult, klienti teha.
Õpetaja: Vist järgmises kursuses Ma mõtlen, ma vist teekski seda teises järjekorras,
Õpetaja: Sest et siis oleks juhtuks naturega. Ja samas praegult on see arutus. Vähemalt siis on ju, et miks, miks mitte nimetada Tt jaoks.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee küsimus. Mis veel kui ülevalt alla liigutada, et kas meil on olemas mingisugune mapper Clientide kohta
Õpetaja: Seega? Silm vajutab plussi läheb Kenasti location I alla.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ee, Jah, et ee. Siin võib ühe asja ära muuta. Kuhu sa Dt ose Ta läheb
Õpetaja: praegu? Ta läheb Persistents kihti. Aga tegelikult me tahaks ta panna. Kuhu?
Õpetaja: Mille kõrvale
Õpetaja: kontrolleri?
Õpetaja: Lähme tagasi, on punkt kontroller.
Õpetaja: Paneme punkt ja paneme Location Controller I juurde.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas ta suudab ära teha. Seal ei ole veel niukest It nimega Tto.
Õpetaja: Aga äkki ta suudab selle teha kui seda siia kirjutada. Will, see
Õpetaja: nüüd on küsimus. Vaata, et me saame nüüd selle Location objekti pealt. Ee, kainda. Natukene Markeerida, et mida me Tahame
Õpetaja: see. Kogu see. Need väljad, mis siin näeme, on selle Location Entity väljad.
Õpetaja: No mis meid võiks huvitada? Kõigepealt see on ju mis me siit valiks Id,
Õpetaja: mis ma nüüd võiksin? Ee, veits korda timmida.
Õpetaja: Ma olen selle nimel
Õpetaja: okei? Et ütleks, et on Location Id, me Saame neid pärast kontrollida niikuinii kui ta on kõik ära teinud.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd Cityname.
Õpetaja: Meil on Objek. Ee, meil on nüüd niimoodi, et Location Objekti sees klassi sees on eraldi Muutuja City objektile. Näete seda siin? See on nüüd. See one Do Many nagu. Vaata, et see on Nagu, Noh, sellepärast ei räägi. Aga siin Viitab sellele, et meil on sõltuvus teisest klassist, kus saab andmeid pärida.
Õpetaja: Kui me selle City valime, Siis City on objekt.
Õpetaja: Point Ongi see, et mis ta nüüd mõtleb. Vaata, et kas me teeme uue Tto klassi,
Õpetaja: mille nimi näiteks tuleb Mingi City Dto
Õpetaja: meil olemasoleva location info. Siis see tuleb Niukene
Õpetaja: klassi sisse tuleb klass ja, tead, ja me tegelikult soovime alati ee võimalikult Lamedat struktuuri.
Õpetaja: Me ei soovi, et objekti sees on. Me ei soovi, et meil Ttodes oleks samamoodi nagu Anettis. Objekti sees on objekt Objekti Sees on mingi väli. Ja edasi me tahame tegelikult mingeid väikseid infokillukesi.
Õpetaja: Me tahaksime niimoodi, et nad kõik oleks eraldi väljas. Ma ei taha, et Mul on City ja City Id ja City name. Tegelt on ainult City name. Ja siis seda ma tahangi, on ju
Õpetaja: ehk, ee, Selleks ka kuskil. Mingi video Võibolla läbi käis, kus natukene jääpis selle kohta, et võiks olla Lame.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See lame. Struktuur ongi. Nüüd. Meil on eraldi individuaalselt võimalik valida mingeid väljumismeid. Siit Huvitavad mitte seda asja objektina näete. See Flat teeb selle asja
Õpetaja: Kas uus klass ja siis Valid väljad. Aa, need on Flat. Ma tahan. Lihtsalt. Anna mulle võimalus. Valida siit mingid väljad. No Mis väljad Ma tahaks sealt City seest Saada
Õpetaja: nimega name. I tahaks saada nii või mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga siin nüüd tuleb väike erand.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, need olid siin kõik lamedad juba iseenesest,
Õpetaja: et mis siin on, et need ülejäänud väljad on? Kõik Flat Id.
Õpetaja: Seal ei ole mitmekihilisust
Õpetaja: seal on niimoodi, et mis iganes Seda pead lihtsalt Teadma. Vaata selle tööriista kohta. Siin on. Nendel on täpselt see, mis sa näed. Selle sa saad Niipea, kui sa tuled, Võtad mingi mitmekihilise objekti ja valitsed selle name I, siis ta tegelikult ise vaikimise Paneb ette juba sõna City selle muuta nime City
Õpetaja: Name. Ta teeb selle Cammal Case. Iga ise City name Iks. Kui siin paned lihtsalt nüüd City name paneks,
Õpetaja: siis ta tuleks City City näima On ju, et seda peab lihtsalt teadma. See on Niuke A. See on selles mõttes, et igal iga, iga kord, kui te teete klassi, Teete ära. Te lähete niikuinii. Peaksite minema vaatama, et. Noh, mis see lõpptulemus jäi ja veel ühe korra mõtlema,
Õpetaja: siis sul on juba vaadata Mingi Jason I vastu. Näiteks sul seal. Ee, Frontis või? Või mis iganes, onju, et. Kas. Kas kõik tundub, et on õige? Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes ei pea liigselt nagu mõtlema refaktoreerida saab pärast väga ilusti, et Lihtsalt, refaktor name ja muudad midagi, Kui tuli valesti ja Nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mis on veel vaja?
Õpetaja: Meil on olemas Location Idi. Meil on olemas Cityname
Õpetaja: lihtsalt Nii see on see, et see on ju Location objekti Name, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga siin on nüüd see värk jälle, et
Õpetaja: et on ee. Tegin mi mitu klõpsu, aga siin on mõeldud, et välja nimi peab olema. Aga meelde tuleks praegu
Õpetaja: lihtsalt näim.
Õpetaja: Validatsioonid, asjad, Las kõik tuleb me niikuinii vaatame selle klassi kenasti üle
Õpetaja: Ja, no siis on see koht. Kas number for Atmsi teisi asju on vaja. Ei ole.
Õpetaja: Praegult on ainult neid kolme välja vaja, vaid on, Okei,
Õpetaja: Küsib, et kas teen ee. Selle mäper klassi ja. Ja kas teen Location infoklassi ja. Ja,
Õpetaja: ee, tema vist meid siis praegu Mäpperi Peale Tegeleme tegema, hiljem et pigem ongi see, et lähme. Näete. Location tuli kenasti ja tegid selle ka.
Õpetaja: Pani Kohe asja ära, On Ju enamus alguritest. Kui niimoodi saab Neid kirjutad juurde. Oskad teha paaril üksikul korral mingi mingisugust teistes kontekstides. Olen näinud, kus ta ei ole saanud sellega hakkama
Õpetaja: siia tulla, Vaatama midagi, et Kas nagu kõik on. Ee, need validatsioonid, mis siin on Location Name i kohta. Me pärime Andmeid andmebaasist.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole vaja midagi valideerida,
Õpetaja: sest need validatsioonid kehtivadki andmebaasil. Nad on andmebaasi pealt. Võite see entiti pealt. Vaata selle Location Name i sisse. Vaata, ütleb Name. I juures on. Max Size on kakssada. Viiskümmend viis. Not on all, on ju? Ta võtab selle pealt, Kui me andmeid lisame või muudame seal, peab olema. Seal on see nagu relevantne
Õpetaja: I love optimizing. No nüüd saabki, vaadata kas on Location Id Citynam Location Name. Võibolla tahad mingit järjestust veel muuta või mida iganes Vaatad need nimed üle. Kui midagi läks valesti, siis ei muuda Lihtsalt siin, sest ta mäpperi tegi ka juba kuskil kasutusel.
Õpetaja: Lähemegi nüüd Mäperisse.
Õpetaja: Tema tegi standard mapperial update.
Õpetaja: Ta teab alati, kasutab seda Inverse Configuration It. Noh, ära kirjuta koodi. Palju, mida meil läheb vaja
Õpetaja: To Dto või Entity.
Õpetaja: Teete üldse et Info läheb ju välja, on ju Entiti tuli sisse.
Õpetaja: Võtame andmed
Õpetaja: ja saadame välja. Kui ei mäleta, siis ee. Läheme lihtsalt sinna Location Servicesse, Vaatame, mida meil on vaja teisendada.
Õpetaja: List Entity test, on onju? Ehk Siis to Dto.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd listist list.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd läheme tagasi sinna, Mapper Isse, või me Läheme mäpparisse. Teised kustutame ära. Esiteks,
Õpetaja: et seda ei lähe vaja. Vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Ei Lähe läheb vaja.
Õpetaja: Väga, Jah, okei, kustutan. Ära Ülejäänud update Pole vaja,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see küsimus. Et meetodi pealt enam ei ole relevantne.
Õpetaja: Kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: Ma selle peale kirjutan. Kellegil on meeles kaardistus,
Õpetaja: Kui See on kaardistaja.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ad. Mapping. Kaardistus. Üks kaardistus,
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia sisse kirjutan Teha Väike niuke template.
Õpetaja: Ee, source, jutumärgid.
Õpetaja: Koma target jutumärgid Nüüd kontroll. Tühik näitab,
Õpetaja: mis nendes klassides on. Sources ja Target is. Vaadake, sorsis on üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus, seitse, kaheksa välja.
Õpetaja: Target is on ainult kolm välja, millele meie alati keskendume.
Õpetaja: Jah, et see on see uus objekt, mida me tahame. Kontoritüük näitab, et on Kolm välja seal. Siis.
Õpetaja: Mitu kaardistust on vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Mitu korda kontroll teed? Valitan kolme, üks, kaks, kolm, kaks. Üks. On juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Nibli Küsimus minule meeldiks, et ee. Et kui see on meie target nii öelda onju, ma korra vahel teen. Niimoodi, et ma tulen ja Copin, Seda võin mina praegu ainult teada Näete ka. Ma vahel teen niimoodi, et ma tahan, et on samas järjekorras ja kui välja on palju, Siis ma ei viitsi meeles hoida.
Õpetaja: Ma korra lihtsalt toon nad siia. Kommenteerin välja, Onju, et see esimene Valley võiks olla siis
Õpetaja: Location It Järgmisena tahaks kaardistada ära City Name I. Ja siis võiks kaardistada. Ära Location name i elav optimizing.
Õpetaja: Noh, need siis võin ära kustutada Kõike Kavatsen vaadata kõik. Kavatsen ära mäppida.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siis see Location objekt, eksole?
Õpetaja: Vaatame, et mis seal source on. Minul on vaja otsida Location Id.
Õpetaja: No mis sobib?
Õpetaja: Esimene sobibki.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Cityname. Aa Cityname Cityname. Cityname City Name, City name.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, Siis hakkame otsima Location I küljest Ma Korra võin piiluda ka.
Õpetaja: Siis Kas siin on Citynam I?
Õpetaja: Siin on City objekt. Kui City sisse minna, siis seal on omakorda objekt.
Õpetaja: Nii, Paneme paar sammu tagasi, on ju? Ahah, okei,
Õpetaja: siit. Ma siis peaks valima Cityname kõigepealt.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, et minna veidi sügavamale
Õpetaja: punkt, nii No saaks trükkida. Ka. Ta aitaks meid, aga niimoodi vaataks.
Õpetaja: Ahah, nii okei. Paigas. Location Jällegi see meie source. Meie source objekt, mis tuleb sisse Ja objekt, mis peab välja minema, onju? Sisse tuleb
Õpetaja: Jah, sest et see on location näin.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas nüüd on kõik Kas Nüüd On kõik olemas, mis vaja,
Õpetaja: kui vaadata Location Service It ja meie missiooni. Meie minimissioon.
Õpetaja: Minimissioon on listist. List on nii
Õpetaja: okei, mis me Vajame juurde, et idee. Aa, oot, oot, oot. Siin. Teeme veits korda tema Tegi väga geneeriliselt. Mis meil siin vajab parandamist.
Õpetaja: Meil on oma Tava Ja arhitektuur, mis siin oleks vaja muuta.
Õpetaja: Mis meetodid siin olid? Mille ma ära kustutasin.
Õpetaja: Mis väravust? Mis siin oli?
Õpetaja: Aa, meetodid, nimed. Ma ütlen, mis siin oli. Mis Margus täna?
Õpetaja: To Entity, see on. See Meetod on
Õpetaja: hästi. Geneeriliselt, aga meie niimoodi ei tee nimetamine on Natukene niukene hägune.
Õpetaja: Aga mis location? Tto. Kus see tagastab objekti? Tule lihtsalt, Copy. See siit onju, et tagastab ju sellist objekti. Meetod peab ütlema, mida ta teeb? Ta tagastab seda objekti
Õpetaja: teeb ümber Location Objekti Location infoks.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd see seda Kas vastab tõele et see niiöelda idee järgi ühe objekti suudab teisendada teiseks objektiks.
Õpetaja: No nende kaardistustega igal juhul suudab. Kui ma panen kiirelt käima, siis ma näen, et ta teeb selle ee meetodi ära. Pildimise käigus siin ühtegi viga ei ole. Siia peaks tulema. I täht Implementation
Õpetaja: Channelite kausta peaks Tulema Location Mapper Imple Class. Kus on see meetod? Ära implementeeritud teki. See lähen vaatan, on mingi Niukene meetod, mis
Õpetaja: vaatab, kas ee sisend on mitte all, Kui mitte, loome uue location Info objekti Seda, mis tuleb tagastama setteritega Target Id
Õpetaja: Source Andmed Classic.
Õpetaja: Aga see on üksikobjekt Kas vastab tõele, et kui me ise praegu. Näiteks siin Four Loobiga hakaks
Õpetaja: või teeks For loopi kõikidest nendest objektidest.
Õpetaja: Igakord saaksime kutsuda välja selle meetodi ükshaaval teisendada kõiki objekte oma listis vastab nii tõele. Aga mehed võiks siis teha siia juurde ühe meetodi
Õpetaja: Control E lükata allapoole ja Timmime ta nüüd niimoodi, et et tema on siis lihtsalt listist List versioon,
Õpetaja: siis see listist list versioon enam ei peaks tagastama. Location Infot, vaid
Õpetaja: ja Üks tõks parem, muidu kui sitta võib selle sõna ära süüa. Vahel vaata, mul on seadistatud, et mitte, aga ma alati lihtsalt väldin seda, et ma teen ühe tühiku ette, et ta ära ja midagi sööks. Ütlen, et list.
Õpetaja: Valin selle Vistnurgalised sulud.
Õpetaja: Panen nurgas, sulud algavad, nurgalised, Sul lõppevad ja liigun edasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on järgmine osa Toolocation Info mis sellega, võiks teha.
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb, et mina. Anna, et Anna mulle Location Info objekt. Tema annab mulle vastu Location info objekti. Aga ta ei anna enam.
Õpetaja: Ja, ee,
Õpetaja: peaks siin olema pigem sest, et Locations info võiks viidata, et see on mingi niukene. Üks objekt. Aga seal on mingi palju asju. Kuidagi mingi väljadega või ma ei tea, mida iganes, sees
Õpetaja: to Location infos. Ma lihtsalt paneks selle mitmusesse ja siin teeme samamoodi praegu. Niimoodi ei saa, olla, et mina annan ainult ühe objekti, Tee mulle tervet list sellest, nagu. Et. Noh, kuidas siis, Kurat, nagu ta ei oskaks.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma ütlen siia ette list, ta saab, aru, et. Aa, aa,
Õpetaja: Nii nüüd. Jumala eest, et ära ei unusta, eks? Mis on vaja siin teha?
Õpetaja: Kas ta võtab sisse? Ma ei Näeks nagu seda tüüpi praegu aga näeks Muutaja nime võtab sisse Location Objekti
Õpetaja: tagastab Toolocation infos. Midagi on nagu valesti.
Õpetaja: On ju et nüüd, on meil. See tüüp muutus. Enam ei ole Location objekt, vaid on
Õpetaja: kõige lihtsam variatsioon Igast. Tühikud. Asjad Mis teil silmi peast ära ei kriibi. Nagu näiteks need siin. Aga minul nagu voolab verd praegult.
Õpetaja: I Love Optimizing. Teeme korda
Õpetaja: sa aru, et okei see, on siis,
Õpetaja: et Tähendab selles mõttes, vaata, et see võib olla mida iganes.
Õpetaja: See võib olla ka mida iganes, aga millega tema toimetab, on ee, et meetodi tüübid. Tema näeb, et sinu tahe on teha, et me saaksime ühe objekti teha teiseks koos kaardistusega, kuidas üks objekt teised on teiseks
Õpetaja: ja Siis Ta nagu kui sa teed niukse meetodi listist list. Kui ma. Kui seda meetrit pole, ta tegelikult ikka üritab midagi, teha, ta lihtsalt ei oska mitte midagi mäppida. Tuleb lihtsalt üks tühi List tuleb põhimõtteliselt, nii.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on niimoodi, et ta näeb. Vaata et hei, sina Tahad listist list meetod teha? Aga ta näeb neid tüüpe ja ta ise teab, et. Kuule, aga mul on olemas. Siin ma saan by Disain ongi mõeldud. Niimoodi need juhendid ongi, Et kui sa tahad listist listi teha, tee kõigepealt meetod, mis teeb seda üksik
Õpetaja: objekti tasandil automaatselt, Kui sa teed niukse meetodi, mis võtab sisse listi kujul, siis ta saab aru, et ta fortsükliga lihtsalt käib seda läbi
Õpetaja: nii mitu korda Ja teiseldab meid. Objekte ja lisab listi, Onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee. See nimi on Kama. Selles mõttes see ei ole vahet. Ja see muutuja nimi On tal ka tegelikult täiesti savi. Teda huvitavad ainult need asjad siin
Õpetaja: ja need saate süsteemist aru, miks ta aru saab, onju,
Õpetaja: ta saab aru, et mul on olemas Niukene meetod, mis seda üksinda ühest objektist teeb teise.
Õpetaja: Kui kasutaja annab märku, et teeks Niukene meetod, siis võtab sisse listi Location objektidest ja tagastab Location infosobjektidest. Siis saab ise, aru, et ta saabki seda meetodit kasutada. Vot siin ongi see, kus te Kus Te rappa lähete? Või Kus Rappa Mindud
Õpetaja: on? Sellega mindud, Et teil ongi vaja seda. Vaata, meil oligi vaja. Pidur oli siin, et Mul on vaja
Õpetaja: teha midagi, mis teeb Locations Objektid Location infodeks. On ju,
Õpetaja: et kui te hakkate kohe tegema seda asja, siis te tulete Siia peale. Hakkate kaardistust panema. Vaata
Õpetaja: midagi. Ee Source source Target.
Õpetaja: Ja siis te hakkate tulema niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No su just.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, aga ma Copy Basen kuskilt. Vaata, Target on Location Id Punane. Äkki töötab Sorson Id Copy Based. Kuskil ei tööta. Ta on vale asja peal
Õpetaja: Listi Sees ei ole võimalik, Map Ida individuaalseid elemente, vaid lihtsalt see on meie soov ja tahe, Aga
Õpetaja: viis ja tehniline võimekus selle saavutamiseks on, Niimoodi, et meil peab olema
Õpetaja: kuskil ise me seda välja hetkel oma koodis ei hakkagi kutsuma Do Location Infot. Aga see meetod siin näete, Kui ma panen pildima,
Õpetaja: kas see on? See on hall? Keegi mind. Ei taha keegi. Mind ei taha keegi. Mind ei taha, niipea, kui ma ära pildin, Peaks juhtuma niimoodi, et keegi seda tahab, aga seda mitte.
Õpetaja: Ta võib siniseks ikkagi minna. Sellepärast, et implementatsioon sellest on olemas. Ma Ei, tea, kuidas ta.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta nagu praegult nagu käitub. Vaata, et kas see jääb halliks. See peaks jääma halliks. Aga Samas jah, Jääb Halliks on nii,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult seda Location infost. Do Location infos. Keegi seda ei soovi. Ma pean uuesti käima, aga
Õpetaja: seda keegi ikkagi kasutab.
Õpetaja: No, sellesama toolocation infos. Niiöelda implementatsioon kasutabki. Näed, see meetod
Õpetaja: viitab siin all Do location info meetodile, mis on siin üleval
Õpetaja: ja meile Põhimõtteliselt antakse juba märku. Vaata, et keegi teda kasutab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Meie tahtsime seda.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis siin toimub. Mitte midagi erilist Ei olegi siin, kui tulla vaatama, et see ongi väga lihtne, et tee üks uus list
Õpetaja: nimega. List
Õpetaja: Noh, täiesti geneeriliselt. Siin sees ei ole vaja teada, et mingi. Ma ei tea. Location info, list või mis iganes. Käime Four tsükliga läbi neid asju, mis meil Locations Entiti objektid
Õpetaja: igal tsüklil. Mu Tee üks muutuja lisalist Jääd meetodiga midagi, aga ennem rehkenda see asi ära, mis listi lisatakse selleks. Käivita siin samas klassis olev meetod.
Õpetaja: Too Location info. Mina annan selle objekti kaasa. Siia käivitub See
Õpetaja: Null ei ole. Loome uue Allocation Info aines, objekti Setter Id Target
Õpetaja: Source info, Anna mulle objekt vastu. See siis rehkendub. Location info objektiks, mis lisatakse listi
Õpetaja: lõpus, tagastatakse list sisse. Tuleb üks list.
Õpetaja: Locations välja. Läheb Location info. Lihtsalt saate temast aru.
Õpetaja: Ta saab aru sellest, mis me tahame. Ülihea, nagu ma ütlen. Ee, see on üks asi, millega ma sain Lhv S ühes arenduses väga rämedalt. Ee, toimetada. Tol hetkel ma poolt nii hästi ei saanud aru, aga ma sain aru, et kuradi hea Asi
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes ma sain kohe aru, et päris hea asi. Noh, see ongi mõistlik
Õpetaja: objektide teisindamine ee. Mis, seal oli vaata? Easyway the Simple Way
Õpetaja: Et, vaata kui, vähe peab koodi Kirjutama me Kirjutasime. Sisuliselt koodi
Õpetaja: üks. Kaks, kolm, neli, viis, rida,
Õpetaja: viis, rida kirjutasin. Meie koodi niimoodi, et me andsime oma intentionist Nagu teada, et mida me üldse tahame. Nagu
Õpetaja: ja Library aitab, siis meil teha lahenduse
Õpetaja: Noh, Vaatame, mitu rida siin koodi on.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi hea vahetused asjad vahele jätta. Aga kolmkümmend viis rida koodi.
Õpetaja: Ütleme nagu mingi, kakskümmend, viis, kakskümmend, Kakskümmend viis, kuni kolmkümmend rida väärtuslikku koodi.
Õpetaja: No kui ma oleks, pean seda ise progema. Vist oleks. Noh, veits oleks Niukene masendus peale tulnud, Onju,
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja. Ta saab, aru mida me tahame.
Õpetaja: Saan aru,
Õpetaja: see ongi Library mõte. Vaata, et nagu keegi on kogu aeg arendajad Istuvad selle mingi sama mustri sees ja et äkki saaks kuidagi lihtsamalt.
Õpetaja: Siis tulebki keegi kokku. Vaata, et Davai teeme niukse, asja,
Õpetaja: proovime seda monetiseerida ka kuidagi. Ja teeme midagi kasulikku. Ja. Või oleme lihtsalt nagu Pakume Community le midagi, et oleme tegelikult arendajad, on niuksed, suht lahked Inimesed,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes nagu, et, ee, et ei ole üldse kahju. Kui minu mingi tehtud asi kedagi aitab ja teeb elu paremaks, nagu See on. Mul ei ole kahju. Vaata, et ma võin teha seda,
Õpetaja: et see on ka see, et suured rahastused seal mingid Ee Facebook, Il ja Google on? Nemad suudavad igasuguseid asju teha. Aga te ei kujuta, kui palju asju suudavad Ära teha lihtsalt inimesed, kes on nagu Tulevadki ainult Community na kaupa ja mõtlevad. Teeme mingi ägeda. Asja.
Õpetaja: Jah, alles ma nägin seda.
Õpetaja: Miimi. Mis see miime oli? Vaata, seal on See, ah? Ma ei viitsi nägin. Ärme räägi,
Õpetaja: Lähme hoopis Ee location aa services. Teeme selle asja ära.
Õpetaja: No võime joone üle enam lõunale, Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd me oleme jälle selles kastikeses Number kaks. Soovime suhelda kastikesega number kolm,
Õpetaja: mis antud hetkel on? Mäper, on nii?
Õpetaja: Siis on meil vaja
Õpetaja: sildikest, et suhelda vastutajale, võiks selle koodila ise kirjutada. Aga kui me hakkame juba siin ka enda selle muutuja nime kirjutama? Location, Mis asi.
Õpetaja: Mäper
Õpetaja: on mäper.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tegi Reale kaheksateist ise.
Õpetaja: Selle sildikese soovisid midagi välja kutsuda. Kuidas teen? Seda
Õpetaja: Boldiga on meie enda kaks Tehtud meetodid. Kumb võiks meile sobida Alumine.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd tema ootab sisse Locations
Õpetaja: Listi objekti. Noh, mängumaa on meil hetkel Baccoine mis meile, võiks sobida Allocations.
Õpetaja: Korra vaatan seda Päris seda meetodit.
Õpetaja: See meetod käivitatakse. Too location infos. Mida see meetod tagastab.
Õpetaja: Listi location infodest Mis me siis Siin teeme. Kutsume välja meetodid, mis midagi tagastab.
Õpetaja: Paneme muutujasse päris elus. See võib olla nii. Ei jääks. Tegelt Siin olukorras isegi jääb nii,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see olemas. On oli eesmärk, et ee. Saame siis nõutud kujul. Ee location info.
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd siis see asi elab ja sureb siin.
Õpetaja: Jah, et ee. Selles mõttes me oleme teises kastis ega paki. Lõpuks annab süsteemist välja. Kontroller
Õpetaja: tuleks talle nagu see, anda vaata, et Kontroller kutsub meid välja. Unlocation Controller. Me ju kirjutasime koodi niimoodi, et alguses midagi ei tagasta. Ja nii edasi. On ju, et Anna mulle Pangaautomaatide asukohtade info on ju? Kui null on City siis tagasta kõik asukohad.
Õpetaja: Tegime niimoodi, et delegeerisime sellele. Ma olen esimeses kastis, Delegeer, käime Läbi need kastid. Panen kõik kinni.
Õpetaja: Esimene kast delegeerib ja elasid teisele kastile.
Õpetaja: Siis me korraks kolistame reposiitorit, küsime andmeid saame andmed kätte,
Õpetaja: siis Ütleme, et tee need ümber. Tuline isegi see kast õigesse kohta on nii. Kontroller Service Mapper, Depositori kolm osalist. See vend korra nagu Pim Pim käib siit niimoodi läbi. Onju?
Õpetaja: Kastide mõttes.
Õpetaja: Noh, me oleme. Saime nagu info kätte. Nüüd on nagu see vend. Tahaks nagu et anna, mulle. Mina tahan kandiku anda. Nagu süsteemist välja kelner. Mitte kelnerile, vaid vastu võtta.
Õpetaja: Sul on see praegult Kogu Kandiks seisab siin Services,
Õpetaja: see See vend polegi, nagu sai oma pulksid ja asjad sinna kandikule kenasti kõik kokku.
Õpetaja: Aga kui kandikat ei anna nüüd sinna sellele tellimuste kontrollijale, Kes kandiku edasi annaks süsteemist välja, siis midagi ei. Juhtu.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me anname kandiku üle,
Õpetaja: et on?
Õpetaja: Ja siin ma nüüd pean ära siis viitama mingisugusele kandikule kui objektile. Aga millel on nimi? Ka küljes, Kus ma Kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Mida me retoorime?
Õpetaja: Jah, viitan sellele sildile.
Õpetaja: Noh, kohe Hakkas ulguma. Kõik on punane.
Õpetaja: Miks tulub?
Õpetaja: Jah, sest alguses, kui me tegime selle meetodi, siis ma veel ei teadnud päris täpselt, mida ta Tagastab või? Me ei tahanud sellega tegeleda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Nüüd see peaks muutuma, et see tagastabki seda
Õpetaja: Sellisel kujul Nõutud infot onju? Listina malt Enter,
Õpetaja: Ta tee siis niimoodi, et Voidi asemel on.
Õpetaja: Aga kas ta.
Õpetaja: Ja kui siin nagu returni osas jõudsime ka edukalt lõpuni, mu küsimus me Sääst saime.
Õpetaja: No, ma ei tea, siit meetodist. Laseme küll jalga. Sellepärast me suutsime selle ära progeda. Noh, siin. Enam midagi meil teha pole,
Õpetaja: Kui ma mõtlen, et returnimees ongi see, et
Õpetaja: seda me. See on. Meetodi definitsioon siin. Praegu,
Õpetaja: See, et ta on sinine, viitab seda, et Keegi kuskil meid välja kutsub.
Õpetaja: Siin on väike vihje Ka Juba ulub juba ette. Ka
Õpetaja: see meetod tagastab mingit asja. Aga seal kus seda välja kutsutakse, siis keegi seda ei kasuta. Seda väärtust. Miks sa oled selline? Noh, esialgu läheks sinna tagasi kontroll, B et
Õpetaja: näemegi, et tõesti Jah, kutsutaksegi ainult ühest kohast ka välja.
Õpetaja: Enne see meetod ei tagastanud midagi. Aga nüüd ta tagastab.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad sellega midagi edasi teha, Siis
Õpetaja: jah. Aint Enter. Pane see muutujasse.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, ta võtab selle meetodi nime pealt. Ma paneks Pigem siin. Infos
Õpetaja: nüüd on see kandid Controller I käes.
Õpetaja: Tema käest See kandik on väike koodi mõttes. See kandik jääkski Selle tellimuste kontrollija kätte
Õpetaja: ise sööb ära. Need burgerid muidugi Ma Ka sööks ka. Aga eks ta Niukene olukorras muidu
Õpetaja: ainult üks töö. Ee, käivitada. Mingi tegevus ja lõpus. Noh, kaks tööd, midagi üle anda potentsiaalselt. No, alati ei pruugi olla. Võib ka olla saada notification. Noh, midagi tagasi ei taha, onju? Lihtsalt mingi süsteem, siis mingi tegevus käivitab.
Õpetaja: Aga antud hetkel on tema ülesanne Ka siis see kandik niiöelda kenasti sealt tagaruumist niiöelda vastuvõttu anda. Siis Ma kirjutan. Siia,
Õpetaja: viitan nüüd Sellele kandikule Kandikule on nimi, mis on kandiku nimi?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga nüüd hakkab. Ee, jälle. Kompilaator hakkab ulguma.
Õpetaja: Miks?
Õpetaja: Jah, et nagu senimaani, kuni ma siia midagi kirjutan. Isegi oli okei. Iseenesest return lauset. Ta ei vihka Sellepärast siis öeldakse, et tagastame tühjust. Palun väga, tagastan Tühjust Siin Ei ole mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole midagi või ühte koodirida.
Õpetaja: Aga kui tagastan mingisugust asja, siis nagu on käärid,
Õpetaja: et see ütleb et ei tagasta midagi ja järsku tagastab, siis. Ei, Sorry, teeme korda,
Õpetaja: palun. Väga. Noh, Siin saaks veel optimeerida koodi, et milleks seda sildikest vaja on, onju? Kui saab otse return I panna, et jutt käib ju objektidest. Üks meetod tagastab ja Tagastame koheselt Selle Veel Viskame veel edasi,
Õpetaja: Aga praegult teeme niimoodi oma projektides. Palun ärge seda tehke. Vot seal juba korra. Võite teha alguses. Noh,
Õpetaja: kogemise käigus, aga nagu te päris Productionist. Saaksite sugeda?
Õpetaja: Proovime ära. Ka. Kas teeb ka üldse midagi?
Õpetaja: Noh, lõunapaus on nüüd siin kuidagi kaugele veninud, aga, ee, vaatame selle viimase asjana ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma tulen, vaatan Sagerit,
Õpetaja: teen refreshing I jaoks üks ee lihtsalt For the tagastab pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot Kui City. On Null tagastatakse kõik asukohad.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma proovin siin nüüd nagu null, Mitu asukohta tuli?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui teil ei ole seda ühte, mida mis Ma siin lisasin juurde. Siis teil pole, onju? Aga tulid kõik
Õpetaja: ette võtta?
Õpetaja: Jah, töötab Frontend Is ka. Loomulikult. Me ju programmeerisime selle teenuse vastu ja meil töötas, siis töötab nüüd ka onju? Kui panen kaks. See peaks olema
Õpetaja: Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma panen kolm on tartu, Kui ma Panen üks ehk pärnu.
Õpetaja: Ee, tühi.
Õpetaja: Aga meil taaskis on öeldud.
Õpetaja: Ei olegi öeldud. On ikka.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, kui ühte kasvukohta ei leidu. Ehk on Selline olukord, et on midagi ei tulnud vastusest. Ma tahan korra panna seda tagasi selle sama ekraani,
Õpetaja: kui tuleb selline olukord, et ta on Tühi massiiv. Selle asemel öeldakse, et peab viskama hoopis errori.
Õpetaja: No location Found ja Nii edasi. See on hästi tehislik. Päriselus Poleks seda vaja. See oleks väga okei Saada Niuke. Vastus
Õpetaja: ei leidnud midagi. Sa oled tühi tühja massiivi
Õpetaja: sest et enamus asjad, kes tarbijad on, vaata, on Programmeeritud nagu Four tsükliga toimetama. Noh, mitu tsüklit tuleb
Õpetaja: null? Selles mõttes taas kuskil asjad katki ei lähe. Vaata. Tabelis näidatakse, et ei olegi seda Dubai hotelli seitsme tärniga saja euro eest.
Õpetaja: On ju, et ee, lihtsalt ei tule. Aga meil lihtsalt siin harjutamise mõttes on tehtud niimoodi, et viska viga.
Õpetaja: No seda me pärast teemegi. Ee, taas keele läbi. Ma teen siis siin. Ee, stopi.
Õpetaja: Lähme sööma.
Õpetaja: Nelikümmend viis Pind Sa Nagu alati. Või midagi muud.